[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yo yo yo yo yo
mic check my check
how's everybody doing tonight
or this morning or this afternoon we
have we have a nice worldwide audience
man
because i get reminded every time when i
i go live around this time because
there's always some people who are like
oh
that's so late for me
like i'm sorry guys i'm sorry
i wish i could be earlier trust me i do
i do
see
there we go somebody in japan
somebody all the way from japan
all
right
oh man oh we gotta fix the
yeah i got a new webcam guys it's pretty
slick
it's pretty slick let me see i need to
move it ever so slightly though nope not
that way
let's see right there
[Music]
there we go
there we go
all right man we got demonic demonic one
early squad i scrolled all the way back
up as far as it would go for me
demonic's the first comment that i saw
so
what's up demonic welcome back we got
purple yeti here nico here pretty early
as well
ct 707 wolf trooper welcome
joey how's it going dude welcome to the
stream
the nose of sauron
what is up nose of sorrow i saw you
hanging out in uh expect a ghost stream
earlier this week
same for feathers mcgraw welcome
feathers a lot of overlap between uh
expecto go and ice chat which is nice to
see man
nice to see i love james and uh and sue
and the chat there
we got stephen rice here welcome steven
oh man i'm gonna botch this name arb
arbelect
ssrb
in brackets there welcome welcome
timothy ninja welcome dude how's it
going
two games to play
miss james stream yesterday glad i could
stop by yours hey nice nice
yeah man it feels like
it's crazy how much
has happened just since we streamed last
so for those of you who may be new here
uh dropping in for the first time we
normally stream on tuesdays
but this tuesday i had to postpone it a
little bit um so we're doing a thursday
night stream instead we'll probably be
back to a regular tuesday next week
but so since i streamed live last
tuesday we had the whole back to
hogwarts thing
which was incredible we got a ton of
news there lots of big stuff uh still
plenty to talk about we're gonna be
talking about some of that tonight if
you guys haven't seen yet on the channel
i have done
extensive breakdowns of slytherin
gryffindor and ravenclaw
hufflepuff's up next that one i'm i'm
i'm aiming to have that one up by
uh saturday
so we'll see how it goes this week was
kind of crazy everything got pushed off
a little bit because
labor day was monday so for those of us
in the us that's a holiday so we were
closed off regular work
monday
kids were out of school so i was home
with the kids that day
goofy gibson welcome to the stream how's
it going
veek
septic op
septic op oh man jai welcome back dude
good to see you again in the chat jai
gucci gabbana says slytherin always oh
yeah let's check the poll
slytherin was dominating moment when i
first put it up if you guys haven't seen
him voted in the poll oh my goodness
where dude where are my gryffindors at
come on now
where the gryffindor's at gryffindor
just we are way behind right now guy 15
uh right now oh it's actually pretty
neck and neck ravenclaw has moved into
the lead ravenclaw at 30 of the vote
right now now to be fair this does not
have to be your house
this is the one that you are most
impressed by of the common room tour the
4k common room tours
that they showed uh on the official
hogwarts legacy youtube account those
the ones we're talking about so
ravenclaw's in first right now 32
percent slytherin second 28 percent
hufflepuffs in third at 26
and then gryffindor's all the way down
at 14
that's kind of surprising but it's kind
of not surprising
[Music]
you're a wizard harry
jason the king jason thank you for
subscribing to the channel
we got shadow guide here as well
part-time vegan i like that name
part-time vegan mr seven digit how's it
going dude welcome welcome
see whiskey did it when it was
pottermore yeah you talk about linking
up the accounts it should have carried
over i think you should still have the
same login even if you haven't used it
in a while
[Music]
part-time vegan did sorting a pottermore
yeah yeah it's the same thing they just
changed the name danny how's it going
danny
duarte welcome back dude how's it going
knows of sauron
jake in the house as well jake aka
hi123 in the chat
also one of our youtube members here
jake how's it going
sue meyer is here as well did i say
danny chris joey
trevor
simeon jordan
or tessa i'm sorry not theresa tessa
johnson tessa welcome claymore plays
how's it going claymore i see you i see
in the chat claymore trevor's gryffindor
nice
every subscribing to the channel thank
you so much
nicholas is here as well
amore poet hey welcome back good morning
poet
l-o-n subscribing to the channel as well
scarlett girl 27 shadow guy see i think
my
i think my chat box just jumped and
skipped a lot of you guys chris d
fuzeale
f-u-z-a-i-l welcome
let's see yeah chris we got oh there's
another i didn't see phantom draws
fandom welcome
one shot welcome one shot rip to the
queen yes indeed
yes wizard
oh man we got a bunch of subs coming
in yeah i've got a a couple of folks i
follow on twitter who live
live in the uk it's like for for the us
we just
it's so hard for us to
comprehend something like that you
know two games to play yo thank you so
much for becoming a channel member here
you just unlocked some slick new emotes
i just saw nico spamming the emotes in
the chat
that is right guys thanks your all
support we unlocked a lot of new emotes
a lot of new emotes
so
here i'm going to spam some too
so you got i can bump them back up to
the top of the chat here so we got
slytherin
we got
uh icons representing each of the four
houses there then we've got the shocked
sorting hat right here
[Music]
we've got an angry voldemort
we've got a laughing house elf
we've got the deathly hallows
symbol right here
and then we've got merlin merlin dude
merlin when he when it's blown up it is
so much cooler but it kind of looks it's
kind of hard to see when it's so small
it's kind of hard to see but i still
love it i think they're all cool and and
at this the rate we're going with
support we're going to unlock even more
mighty flux with the one dollar super
chat mighty flux thank you so much
[Music]
but yeah very sad about the queen i mean
what was she 96
and she's like one of those people i
mean i'm sure there are some people out
there who
you know were didn't like her for
whatever reason but i mean
it's hard in this day and age to have
that many people who just almost
unanimously i'm not gonna say
unanimously nothing's unanimous anymore
i feel like but
just like almost everyone just talking
positively about her it's amazing
feathers oh i didn't realize you're in
the uk feathers feeling so shocked
didn't expect to be so sad about the
queen
nico hey nico with the gifted sub nico
thank you so much for gifting the sub
let me scroll down here and check in on
that super chat guys if i missed you
sorry about that
um oh mighty flux was just uh
mightyfox didn't have a comment
mightyfox was just saying hello welcome
to griffin shadow guide shadow guy thank
you so much shadow guy becoming a member
here as well
let me see if this works i uh i tried to
add
i think it's join
let me see if join works here
maybe maybe not
oh didn't work
that's weird yeah i tried to program
some new uh
let me try it in a different spot
right here maybe
nope not working at all huh
i'll have to see if i can figure that
out i'm supposed to have uh like the
stream elements chat bot because we get
a lot of people who ask like how exactly
do you go about joining
so joining is a totally completely
optional you guys it's if people want to
support the stream
monetarily and get you know some fun
little emoji for doing so
uh you can do that i think it's like
4.99
so it's like a little join button below
the uh the video or there's also like a
little money sign somewhere in the chat
area
let me try this this one's actually for
for twitch so just ignore this
exclamation point prime here but
i want to see if it were okay yeah none
of them were working all right i'm gonna
fix that i don't know what's going on
there
yo we got another super chat from mighty
flux
mighty flux thank you so much
a five dollar super chat coming in that
time i feel that we saw a lot of the
gryffindor common rooms in the house so
it no longer impresses us it's more of
how accurate it can be to the movie
i feel that too yeah i totally get that
it's it's the one that they had the most
to work with so in one way it was kind
of easy because they already had so much
but also
it's difficult because you got to make
sure you please the fans you know and
you got to want to you know they kind of
want to put their own spin on it too i'm
sure
steven rice with the 499 super chat or
no wait that's a sticker
a super sticker that stephen shared
there nice
oh you're trying to join yeah so if
you're trying to join you should be able
to find a uh
[Music]
oh let's see i don't want to
[Music]
actually does this this is where we're
getting our royalty-free music for the
night guys beautiful tavern medieval
tavern music medieval end volume one
relaxation harmony the website if you
want to check them out here
um but yeah theirs doesn't have a join
button
let me pull up
let me pull up somebody in another
window here
see i'm already um has to be somebody
that i've not already joined
i've already joined expecto go's channel
actually you know what it might show up
on my own channel
yeah here it is here it is
so this is my channel uh this little
join button right here
so the join button right here there you
go so you'll get these little loyalty
badges next to your name so it starts
with the blue one and then like the
longer you stay as a member it goes all
the way up to i'm pretty sure i set the
circle one here for like the one year
but yeah then you'll get these little
emoji that you can use in the chat also
recently added a 15 discount on merch as
well so you unlock all that when you're
a channel member
did i see jay rossi in the chat as well
jay rossi what's up how's it going dude
yeah thank you guys so much for the
super chats and for the new members dr
sherbert looking forward to the
hufflepuff room yeah that's the that's
the final one that i've got to uh
get complete
purple yeti with another super chat two
dollar super chat come on gryffindors
get your act together
i know right we're the gryffindor it's
gryffindor guys still
still bringing it up in the rear 14
right now i'll be honest with you guys
like i'm gonna do a full
so as you all already know i've done
like a deep dive on three of them so far
so i don't want to speak definitively
because
i mean i've seen the new hufflepuff
trailer but i've not really done that
deep dive just yet
i haven't i haven't done that you know
looking over it with a fine tooth comb
really going all in watching it you know
0.5 speed is what i slow these down to
when i'm going back so i don't want to
say definitively yet i will say from the
first reveal
not the most recent common reveal the
first reveal hufflepuff was at my top i
thought they just absolutely knocked it
out of the park
part of that is exactly what we were
just talking about though how
gryffindor's we have seen it so many
times already we saw it in our heads
reading the book very vividly very
clearly that's where harry ron hermione
i mean they lived there then we saw it
in the movies and we've seen it in the
video games we've seen it many many
times and we've only seen a little bit
of the others so a little bit of
slytherin
a little bit less of ravenclaw a little
bit less of hufflepuff
did i see uh let's see
oh wait wait wait wait wait
red linus uh welcome back
you can super chat on iphone demonic
once that's right i remember people
talking about if you're on mobile so if
you guys are on mobile and trying to
join
i didn't confirm this but uh people were
saying it expect a ghost chat it sounds
accurate to me is that for some reason
you can't uh
you can't join on mobile i don't know
why they haven't added that yet
[Music]
mighty flux slytherin interest is the
only thing that's hype otherwise it's
okay for the entrance is
it's pretty awesome though right
it's pretty awesome
[Music]
stargazer tim hey tim welcome nah you
haven't missed much at all
you have not missed much at all starry
night a starry night welcome thank you
so much for subscribing to the channel
you're a wizard
drip from japan subscribing as well
stephen i'm subscribed to your channel
if that's what you mean oh so
it works a little bit differently here
on youtube than on twitch ellen jackson
subscribing as well so
their terminology is basically flipped
so on
bob phillips subscribing to the channel
as well thank you bob so on twitch
it is you pay for a subscription you're
a wizard and follows are free
so here on youtube dr evil to be
subscribing as well
uh on youtube the subscriptions are free
so all these people you see right now
that is just the the youtube subscribe
button so just like you would go on any
channel on youtube and you're like hey i
like this channel i want to you know see
more from them
so show some support for them you can
subscribe to the channel for free noth
you know it's just tied to your youtube
account
the joining is a membership thing that
youtube added
gosh i don't remember when they added it
but it's it's kind of like to compete
with twitch so the twitch subscription
is basically the youtube membership so
yeah that's what we're talking about
there the people that are joining and it
has a little you'll see a different
alert when people join so
your video common room is good oh yeah
yeah i already read that one yeah so i
again i don't want to speak
out of turn here
because i still got to review the
hufflepuff common room fully but i'm
digging the gryffindor common room guys
and i wasn't when i did my other review
if you guys um
on my channel here so these are the ones
i've done so far ravenclaw gryffindor
slytherin right here uh but i actually
added some new playlists recently we had
so many hogwarts legacy
stuff going on
that i had to break it down so now i've
got a playlist for hogwarts legacy lore
theories and speculation
35 videos there hogwarts legacy common
rooms revealed for only four there so
far
and then let's see we should also have
the uh
hogwarts legacy news updates that one's
got 71 so that's where the bulk of
everything is going
but um in this one right here
oh come on that's not what i want to do
you can see it over here on the right
ranking all the common rooms in hogwarts
legacy so i did this one back in april
just based on the limited look that we
had seen
and i kind of ranked them there
but um let me go and let this play i'll
get it i can
yeah this is crazy you have to watch uh
ads on your own videos
it's it's it's mind-blowing to me
all right so
[Music]
let's see if we can get my finishing so
yeah this is this was my previous
opinion
and i can say definitively it has
changed
it has it has definitely changed
again i can't say for sure yet because i
have not fully reviewed hufflepuff but
gryffindor's moved up a lot for me
gryffindor's moved up a lot
and i was i was frankly a little bit not
disappointed in the gryffindor common
room it didn't wow me in that first view
now after this most recent look though
man i'm so much more excited for it
i really am so much more excited
tasbord a thank you for showing the
support tazbar listen while you're at
work yeah dude feel free to throw it on
in the background this is almost just
like this this show here you know
there's some visual elements as well but
it's almost kind of like a live podcast
kind of like a radio show so if you guys
want to you know i've thought about
what any of you guys be interested at
just let me know in the chat if any of
you would be interested at all and
having this uploaded somewhere as a
podcast lon lon thank you so much for
the super chat or lon you got the
periods in between there
thank you so much for the 1.99 super
chat um but yeah if you guys think
that'd be a cool idea because it
wouldn't be
[Music]
i haven't done any podcasting stuff in a
while but i don't think it would be that
difficult to set up it might be kind of
weird though if i'm calling out like
super chats and stuff i don't know how
that'd be for podcast format but
all right so lon asks i wonder if
there's common room seeking
via magic
common room seeking via magic i'm not
sure i'm understanding the question
there
don't don't don't you don't have to
super chat again though if you want to
clarify in the just a regular comment
i'll try and catch it see if i can
figure out what you mean there i wonder
if there's common room
seeking via magic you mean maybe like so
we you might be talking about the flu
flames that are in the common rooms
jason how's it going jason
oh yeah machop definitely new tier list
definitely a new tier list
only 49 likes keep it going show some
love hey chris thank you so much timothy
says yo we're at 77 nice
yeah likes help other people find the
video guys so
if you want to spread some love if you
want to show some support
totally free no you know not like a
membership or anything hit that thumbs
up button they just tweeted about new
gameplay wait right now
let's see here
hogwarts legacy
uh latest tweet i got from hogwarts
second seas seven hours ago
sadly
explore hogwarts in style with the house
fanatic school robes follow the steps at
wizardingworld.com legacy connect to
import your house in one and receive
this full set of rows and big skull
masks mighty flux with a two dollar
super chat as well mighty flux thank you
so much
starkeys are tim i like them all but
even though i'm a hufflepuff i
personally found ravenclaw to be most
impactful but again i thought they were
all fantastic
dude
it's so funny to me that ravenclaw is my
most is the longest one right now i
think the slytherin one was like nine
minutes the gryffindor one was like 13
14 minutes i believe and then the
ravenclaw one was 16 minutes
i'm like what
because i
my gut reaction
after recording the three of them was
like oh man i don't feel like
ravenclaw's had as many secrets
and then i'll look at the timing of the
video and i'm just like oh i guess it
did
maybe not secrets maybe just more i
didn't feel like it had as many hidden
details or anything like that so
yeah jai i think i'll go hero path first
shadow guy think this could be a cool
podcast
oh elon said it's meant to say sneaking
okay gotcha all right so let me get ello
in super chat and then mighty flux i'll
get your super chat here so uh elon
wants to know i wonder if there's common
room sneaking via magic okay
that makes a lot more sense like
sneaking into the other common rooms and
nico with another gifted membership hey
guys make sure you think nico if you're
one of the ones who just received a
gifted sub you might or excuse me not a
gifted sub a gifted membership it looks
like it was jason hodges
or jason hodges just became a member of
one of the two but uh if you got gifted
make sure you uh
thank nico for the gift of membership
there
so i i do think there's gonna be a way
to sneak around yeah i think that is
such a
like a staple of the series
that
i feel like they they really have to
have something like that
have i not liked this yet
so i do i think i think they will have
some way
even if we don't have an invisibility
cloak
hey tara coming in with the 3.89
super chat as well tara thank you so
much
very much appreciated
so yeah element i do think they're going
to do it we've already seen the
disillusionment charm at one part not
really a common room part but a part
like showing the stealth and we know
stealth's going to be an option for the
combat so yeah i think they're going to
have us sneaking around at night too
apolly juice we know paula juice is in
the game that could be another way to
get into common rooms as well
you guys are saying 100 on a podcast
would for sure james also listening at
work nice nice
jake says guess what ooh i'm on the edge
of my seat
let me know jake let me know all right
so mighty flux is super chat and then
we'll get to the other one that just
came in there
um houses and element spells examples
slytherin water oh what do you think
about houses and like basically
representing elements
i'm trying to remember if jk rowling
ever commented on that because you're
right i mean they people do
traditionally
associate you know slytherin with water
gryffindor with fire ravenclaw with air
and um hufflepuff with like earth
two games to play with a gifted
membership as well
yo thank you so much two games to play
for gifting that membership
[Music]
and it looks like the potter legacy
that gifted membership man you guys are
showing some crazy support out of the
gate here tonight thank you all so much
so yeah i mean i definitely see that i
do and even if you think about like
i don't know it probably doesn't work
for the color so much
it doesn't work for the color so much
because you think slytherin green
traditionally think of that being more
with
the earth
but i mean gryffindor clearly fire
[Music]
i love that though i do
joey just messing with you keep you on
your toes wait what did joey say oh they
they just cheated about come on joey
don't do that to us now don't do that to
us
phantom draws i'm so tired
arkham knight yeah we'll we'll see where
ravenclaw falls when i uh
re-rank them
[Music]
stephen rice that's like yeah i guess if
you're on mobile for whatever reason
that's they gotta add that i mean that
seems like a big especially if they're
trying to compete more with twitch it
seems like something that'd be easy to
add but it took twitch a long time to
add subs on mobile as well
and the way they do it it's really weird
it's like you have to buy these tokens
first through the app store because it's
like
anything bought on the phones like apple
and google want to take their it's a
really weird
system how it all works
all right let's get that other super
chat actually we had i think we had two
super chats that came in
let's see so tara says literally spent
an entire day last week binge watching
your hogwarts legacy playlist tara thank
you so much
not even a question tara just showing
sport there that's awesome to hear yeah
that's why i
i made those playlists i mean i actually
was thinking the other day i was like
should i go in and unlist because every
now and then i'll get some comments on
the older videos like talking about how
things are
how i'm way wrong in the video and i'm
kind of like did you look at did you
look at the date on that like when when
we recorded
we were going based off almost no
information when we made some of these
videos so but then i decided you know
what i'll just leave them up people
could see the date on there i'll put
them in the uh a different playlist
that way if people just want to see like
kind of the history of the hogwarts
legacy like the news and everything like
the hard news like this is what we know
things that were confirmed news bits
that we got from avalanche they can go
and see that and then i made a different
one that's going to be kind of like our
lore
theory speculation that sort of thing
inevitably every video that i make
that's like meant to be a
speculation-based video
there'll always be comments of people
saying like this video is holding
absolutely nothing new i'm like
it's
we're discussing
like that's that's the point there's no
news we're discussing the game that
isn't out yet kind of blows my mind
yeah gabe is right autodesk did finally
release the um
the little kind of behind the scenes
look
great for while you're eating nice
and then we had the other super chat
coming in from aspect see the hogwarts
legacy video on the autodesk channel
yeah let's go ahead and pull that up
here
[Music]
because i heard that they that it was
actually
slightly different or not slightly
different but they uploaded the um
like the full quality
of the cut scene at the end so this this
whole thing was amazing i don't know how
much of this we're allowed to uh
i heard some people that have posted
like the full cut scene of the other one
we're getting
some copyright thing so i'm not going to
have the sound on but
this was actually really uh we'll kind
of just kind of skim through it here so
we don't just let the whole thing play
a lot of it is very technical if you
guys haven't seen this though and you're
hyped for the game definitely go check
it out because there's a lot of fun
stuff here where they talk about kind of
their behind-the-scenes process so
here's like the overview right here if
you're wondering
what all they cover in
this mightyflex there's a theory where
each house will associate with specific
elements
yeah i could i mean that it definitely
makes sense to me
it definitely makes sense
amazing cjb how's it going welcome
but everything changed when the water
tribes attacked wait what wait what is
that how it happened oh man
it's almost time for my
my oldest son is eight and i'm like dude
i really i really want to show him
avatar last airbender i know he'll love
it but then that part of me is like do i
want to wait till my
other son's old enough to watch it too
which you know the show is great they
they can handle everything in there i
just want them to be old enough to where
they'll like remember it you know and
appreciate it oh that show is so good
levi says the wand detail in ravenclaw
was interesting they did it in the
gryffindor one two oh did they okay
so
if you guys didn't see this
we're gonna be pulling up multiple video
multiple videos here
i'll actually pull up my video from uh
today on this one so the ravenclaw
common room video
[Music]
so there's a shot that in the gryffindor
one i totally missed
to where
when the student goes
oh man come on give me a better look
it's so blurry right there
[Music]
i think it's right in here
[Music]
oh yeah it's right here toward the end
okay
hey thank you so much for those uh
recent subs that just popped in welcome
welcome
so right here remember the gryffindor
common room shot or scene where they uh
they interact
with the little um what is this thing by
the way guys
i keep wanting to say glow but i'm like
it's not a globe
it's definitely something to do with
astrology right i just keep calling it
this spherical object but anyway you get
the square button prompt look see how
the character right here there's nothing
in their hands here and then i'm just
gonna play it at
let's play it at 0.25 speed
[Music]
oh well i'm probably talking over it
right now that's why it's not playing
[Music]
okay here we go
[Music]
come on retro get on with it
let me just put it back at normal speed
okay there we go i actually slowed it
down in the
in the video so look at that right there
you can see this one just like appears
it's like it was hidden up in their
sleeve
now you can see they're still holding it
down here and then when they walk on a
little bit forward they're still holding
it
[Music]
whoa this is kind of trippy seeing the
other
there's two mice on the screen
what's happening what's going on
so i think that's what that comment was
saying right there is that this also
happened in the uh
[Music]
gryffindor scene as well because
gryffindor also has a moment where they
interact with the little
object there
[Music]
phantom draws less oh wait what do you
what are you guys talking about watching
here
are you talking about the autodesk
session
or wait you might be talking about
something else
if you're talking about this though i
definitely think it's worth the watch
maybe not through the whole hour
but you can watch it at like double
speed or something
throw on some music and and pick out the
parts that are interesting or you can
watch my my breakdown video of it
because i have a breakdown video a few
weeks back when all of it first came out
breaking everything down um honestly the
biggest things of interest were in a lot
of these shots here
there are various spots where we can see
different file names
and some of the file names were things
that we would recognize from the series
that we didn't know about yet like
deathly hallows
is in one of the file names
um battle of hogwarts is another thing
in one of the file names and there's a
lot of stuff where they they talk about
the mocap
and how they were having to record this
during covid so it was really weird oh
dang it
youtube's funny about when he used that
word
um
during this uh thing that went on around
the world
how it kind of had to change their their
plans for how they were recording
everything and shooting everything
because everything was being done
remotely actually really fascinating and
shows you how that did kind of throw off
everything for them
but i thought it's pretty interesting
right here this is one that people were
talking about
on the subreddit
melissa leeds with the is that a 50
super chat
excuse me
what
what
melissa oh my goodness not even a
question sharing a super sticker there
i believe that is 50 u.s dollars
melissa thank you so much way too kind
of you
way too kind of you melissa
very much appreciate it
i'm just like i'm just in shock right
now like
youtube's it's kind of weird how youtube
because youtube accepts like all
different kinds of currency so sometimes
you'll see there was one in james's chat
the other day it looked like a hundred
dollars i think it was like actually
five us dollars
whatever that is
thank you so much melissa whether it's
fifty dollars or five dollars or two
dollars
that is so kind of you i really really
appreciate it thank you very much
[Music]
yeah nice donation indeed do you think
we'll go underwater at least see the
creatures
i keep going back and forth on that one
i keep going back and forth on that one
i do
jordan i was really impressed how
avalanche explained in the autodesk how
they were able to take different film
sequences from different days right
that was so mind-blowing
i mean just like how they
[Music]
all the all the different things they
had to consider
to make people feel like with it when
they were in the same room when they
were actually remotely it's nuts oh wait
the global thing is called an or orey
i have ne i don't think i've ever heard
of that probably a type of globe
astro glo danny says astro globe machop
said astro globe
[Music]
interact with the astro globe all right
we got to look this up now by the way
happy birthday to uh or happy late
birthday to jake jake turning 16.
nice
[Music]
now melissa with another another five
dollar super chat melissa oh my goodness
everyone is excited for the new game and
prices are sadly a lot of money i hope
it helps melissa that is way too kind of
you
oh my goodness melissa thank you so much
i hope you are looking forward to the
game as well which uh what are you gonna
be playing on melissa gonna be playing
on a console a pc
playstation xbox
but yeah this this is something i saw
people talking about on the uh
subreddit earlier is um
weasley's confirmed to sit in chair
at some point
weasley's confirmed to be sitting in
chair i think professor weasley is uh
not the redhead
i think professor weasley is the one
that sits the sorting hat on the
head of the main character
so that we explore that in my autodesk
breakdown video as well
[Music]
the original soundtrack cd should oh my
goodness j rossi right
i feel like there were a couple of
low-hanging fruit opportunities that
they really missed for the collector's
edition i mean price aside like pr it is
it is very high priced yes but they
could have put enough high quality
things in there i think to justify the
price there's no art book in there
there's no original soundtrack in there
like you mentioned i made a tweet on
twitter today saying they should have
included some replicas of those house
robes
the house fanatic robes are incredible
man this would have been way too complex
i admit
in terms of like managing supply chain
issues and all that but
just like just imagine for a brief
moment guys if they did like house
themed editions
can you imagine if they had like house
themed collectors editions
even if it was like like sort of order
by um
oh jeez what's it called where you like
you only place the order when you
however they wanted to do it you know
where they could set it up easily on
their website
even if they don't want to go ahead and
make enough basically they don't want to
make it until they know people are going
to buy it i get that
but imagine if you could buy a house
edition that's like your scarf it's like
a robe
oh and plus the magic one plus the
original soundtrack anyway don't get me
started on the collector's edition man
it's just like oh
it's not that i'm angry i'm more like
sad and disappointed because i know
people were so pumped for that
and it was like it would have been so
easy to do
i mean they're literally you can go to
the official harry potter shop online
right now and there are these trunks of
of items cheaper than that that are like
amazing
melissa going to be playing on ps5 nice
i am i am
90 sure that's where i'm going to be
playing as well
90 sure
with an outside shot at pc the only
only way i would go pcs if the ps5
version just
once we start getting word about
how the game runs if it just runs like
terribly other than that i'm i'm pretty
sure i'm going ps5
multiple weasleys i don't think multiple
weasleys i think this is all referring
to the uh professor weasley or actually
no there will be multiple weasleys
because there's going to be at least one
weasley as a student
for sure and they've they've practically
confirmed that that they're going to be
multiple weasleys
pc mods yeah there should be some
amazing mods
i don't think we're gonna be able to
interact with the giant squid levi but
they already talked about
chandler made the joke of like don't tap
on the glass
so i think they got to have something
that happens when you're in the
slytherin common room and you like go
and you you tap the glass i don't know
if it's a mermaid
i don't know if it's like
it starts to crack or something and you
have to like repair it
i think it's i think a giant squid would
be hilarious
i do i think that would be really funny
oh yeah you should definitely check out
the books if you haven't read the books
oh so good fandom so good even if you've
seen the movies the books are just like
far and away
yes i would have halfway paid 300 for a
house edition right i mean
i i really like i know money is tight
right now for a lot of us and that is
totally understandable
but it's more just about the it's not
even the 300 it's just that it's like
it's just
the one
and the steel book okay
it's like oh man
so many more things you could have done
there
roughly five waited i see uh i hate how
the uh the chat box jumps around on me
like roughly five months till the game
comes out oh my goodness
that's crazy
stephen fry favorite orator
of the harry potter audiobooks
oh yeah both stephen fry and and jim
dale do a great job
they do a great job oh yeah but i wanted
to look up
i wanted to look up those terms you guys
were throwing out there
for the uh somebody said
i want to look up
orrery that's actually hard it's hard to
say
orary
i want to look up that one first
[Music]
oh i think you guys might both be right
orary might be like the simplified way
of saying it or or
orrery or it's our arri
hold on let's let's meet the music for a
second here
nope that is not the music that is the
music right here
listen guys
okay
an apparatus for representing the
positions motions and phases of the
planets satellites etc in the solar
system
second definition any of certain similar
machines as a planetarium
i think that is spot on and then some
some of the others were saying we had
quite a few people saying astroglobe
oh nope not a j on the end
astro lobby
an
astronomical astronomical instrument for
taking the altitude of the sun or stars
and for the solution of other problems
in astronomy navigation
used by greek astronomers from about 200
bc
interesting
yeah i think it's arie
i think that was that tim who said that
i think you nailed it tim horry it is
see i learned something new man
always learning something new 95 likes
and counting yo let's go
amore poet unless uh it comes out on the
ps2 you won't be playing
wow is that the last time you had a
console
amazing
pre-order deluxe for ps5 slytherin prize
says we got rossi representing the xbox
series s
melissa elites oh my goodness melissa
you guys
with another super chat
melissa what is happening
another of five dollars
can you shout out my friend tech vr he's
in the stream somewhere and enjoys your
vids dude
of course melissa thank you so much
tech vr
what's up thank you so much for
supporting the stream both of you both
melissa and tech vr really appreciate
your support
and uh and yeah that you enjoy the vids
that's awesome there were so many like
you guys know how it is on youtube man
you get a lot of crazy comments dude you
get a lot of crazy comments by and large
you guys are i mean my audience is great
so there are a couple of comments today
that just like really i don't know man
they just really like
hit home with me in a in a positive way
i posted one on twitter somebody talking
about how they had a rough day at work
and just like
being able to come home and relax and
and see a full breakdown of their house
which was ravenclaw was awesome
and i'm just like man you know what
that's just such a good reminder for me
i mean it's why it's why i do that it's
why i do this really you guys like to
hear people say that it it on i mean it
truly means the world to me man truly
means the world that is that is why i i
mean that's what keeps me going you know
that's what keeps me doing this
james with a super chat as well j oh and
you asked what house i am gryffindor
melissa gryffindor yes indeed
i have a video up on the channel where i
take the uh sorting quiz so if you wanna
it's it's the pottermore questions but
all of the pottermore questions
so i think when you do the pottermore
quiz it only asks you like i still call
it pottermore i know it's wizarding
world now but
i i i do one that includes all of the
questions
because i think it just gives you i
think it's more fun gives you a better
result but yeah i'm pretty much
gryffindor and
95 of the sorting tests that i've ever
taken
since harry potter came out and i've
been following it for a while i've
almost always gotten gryffindor there's
like a couple times when i get ravenclaw
but yeah
that i mean 95
i'm gryffindor gryffindor through and
through but uh james dude james thank
you so much for supporting the channel
as well the 7.99 super chat do you think
the tapestry in the slytherin common
room suggests male and female dorms i
noticed the female tab she said well i
think all of the dorms will have like uh
sides for boy girl yeah that's thing
from the books and
it's actually kind of funny because
there's there's a comment in the books
when harry and ron try to run up into
the uh
the girls side they're trying to run
over there and tell hermione something
and the stairs actually turn into a
slide
so they they're like bewitched to keep
the boys from sneaking into the girls
dorm which i love i think the ravenclaw
when you can pre see
pretty clearly it's the knights that are
standing guard on one side i think the
night side is the girls side
but i i did see that in the slytherin
one about
[Music]
let me pull up that video as well
uh let's see we need a couple new tabs
here
[Music]
let's see hogwarts legacy slytherin
yeah we'll pull it up in 4k too
man i just i love that they uploaded
these in 4k so if you guys haven't seen
he's talking about this right here on
the left
yeah i i really try to do some digging
on both of these actually like emily
over here it looks like emily and then
this one almost has like howard
[Music]
looks to me like howard so i tried to
find like famous slytherins from history
none of those names really popped up so
a lot of this is gonna have to be you
know stuff that they made up within the
world
because i don't know how much they
worked with
i'm sure they had a ton of stuff being
that they're working directly with wb
and under port key games and i'm sure
they had a back backlog of
of information to pull from
will i be doing four playthroughs oh man
i think i mean
we'll see we'll see a minimum of two
playthroughs
minimum of two because i gotta do like
good and evil even if there's not
different endings which i think there
will be different endings shout out to
james at expect to go by the way check
out his video from today
um breaking down why he thinks
the two covers actually suggest
different endings
which i i agree with him i think he's
spot on i think he's spot on but james
thank you so much for the super chat i
do think you are right
i think this is representing uh boys and
girls and probably with this the stairs
here as well
i bet the right is gonna be the boys
side and the left will be the girls side
tasman with a super chat as well tazbar
thank you so much the 10 super chat at
work now unfortunately keeps cutting out
for me oh man sorry to hear that have to
listen to this after you wrap up have a
good night retro chat tasmart thank you
so much man i'm sorry i have in trouble
with the uh
one thing you could try is youtube will
let you if you hit this little uh
let me minimize this so you might be
able to see it
on the live stream it should also have a
little cog wheel like this
and you should be able to turn down the
quality
of the stream so that sometimes that
helps if you go in and
maybe turn that down that might help you
a little bit but if you gotta if you
gotta run i totally get that too totally
understand
jake with a super chat as well mike you
guys
you are being way too kind with the
super chats tonight
holy cow man
maybe dude what's going on thursday like
maybe maybe i need to move the streams
to thursday
seriously guys thank you so much support
is very much appreciated uh that is jake
by the way i remember jake's name
instead of calling him hi one two three
every time
say okay do you mind if i call you by
your actual name instead of uh saying hi
one two three guess what grade you got
you're a wizard did i see my donor from
podcast now i think the discovery tour
would be great for people who want to
explore hogwarts uh i do think i
remember a donation popping in from you
when we were uh so yeah that was
actually hosted on um podcast now's
channel so the donation would have went
to him
but um that was super fun if you guys
didn't see that
probably several of the content creators
that you watch
dude here and here come the
subscriptions pouring in thank you guys
so much welcome to the new subs
you're a wizard harry
but yeah we did a uh a live stream with
myself
alex from podcast now james of expecto
go
ben benjamin snow from benjamin snow
and andy reloads from andy reloads
four other
guys who have
really covered a lot of hogwarts legacy
and we
we really had no intention i don't know
if they maybe they had a plan i don't
know but i think none of us were really
we knew we wanted to do it go for an
hour so maybe hour or two
we ended up chatting for four hours you
guys four hours we did a four hour live
stream
uh honestly like
talking with uh with each other like
throwing out theories throwing out ideas
and then interacting with the chat as
well so i did see your uh comment jake
thank you for showing the support there
oh your driving test that's what you
were talking about nice you got a 93 on
the driving test
that's passing right
back when i took it it wasn't like it
wasn't a great it was like you either
passed or you failed that was it there
was no score
but i think 93 is probably passing
congratulations dude
christy first stream i've joined hey
christy welcome thank you for stopping
by
yeah so for those of you who are maybe
new here and have seen some of the
videos on the channel you might be
checking out the stream for the first
time or maybe you've never seen any of
the videos maybe you saw it on on
twitter
maybe you just saw it pop up on youtube
i don't know if that happens if you've
never watched any of my videos maybe it
could still pop up but whatever
this is a weekly live show that we do
really um just chatting about kind of
harry potter right now it's focused on
hogwarts legacy um but video games in
general as well uh as we as we
eventually move past hogwarts legacy
once the game comes out which
still seems like so far away we'll we'll
cover some other topics but yeah most of
most of our streams right now are
dedicated to hogwarts legacy so
appreciate you all stopping by and
hanging out
uh dutch says i wonder if you try to uh
go to the opposite sexes dorm room if
that will happen yeah i think so
i oh man
that was because like if you look at the
ravenclaw one
we're gonna have to pull all we need to
pull all these up let me keep the uh
actually i should just
let's go to the hogwarts legacy page
right here
if you look at the ravenclaw one
so this shot actually might be more
toward the beginning
yeah it's right here
this shot right here my guess
is that this side is the girls and if uh
the boys try to go in there they just
like
block them
and then this side is the open side
that's my guess
[Music]
patronus is a heron
nebulon cat
this is a dragon oh that's awesome
hey zootora zoo zootara zutara thank you
so much for the super chat the two
dollar super chat do you have a tick
tock i do have tick tock
it's also at retrorecontour uh i will
tell you i do not have a lot of posts on
there
andy reloads speaking of andy we're
talking about the live stream we did
andy was really encouraging us to uh get
on tick tock because
he was saying he's had a lot of success
with some of his uh
hogwarts legacy stuff over there
so i've put a few things over there a
few of my hogwarts legacy videos i've
kind of uh distilled down
but yeah i'm thinking about maybe trying
to do a little bit more on there it's
just like it's just an issue of time
really
it's it's an issue of time like how much
time i have with my regular job and
family
work family life all that
[Music]
but yeah if you guys want to check it
out i do indeed have a tick tock
andrew says i got into your content the
past few weeks uh figured i could join a
stream hey thank you andrew yeah glad
you found the channel
slitheree
finally got to catch one of the streams
yeah welcome
[Music]
lionel whisker knot dude that is a great
name
that is a great name i suspect all the
ones will get small bonuses to certain
spells depending on wood and core doubt
linked as a factor more of a measurement
of character potential i can't wait to
see how they handle the wands nico with
another gifted membership and look at
that how are you
welcome to gryffindor oh sith ray i
thought it was slytherin
still a cool name still a cool name
how are you
welcome oh dude back-to-back memberships
right there also ct 707 wolf trooper
becoming a member as well yeah guys so
if you uh click the little uh emoji icon
you'll see for those of you who just
became members and got gifted
memberships you will see that you have
some new emoji that you can use in chat
and we just have some brand new ones
that
as harry potter fans i think you guys
might recognize a few of these
i think you might recognize a few of
them
yeah there you go nico in the chat
throwing them out there so everybody
could see
i love
i love them all but i think like
i think the sorting hat might be my
favorite one i went with a shocked
reaction for the sorting just like
sorting hat just in total shock
nico dude just dishing out the gifted
memberships tonight
[Music]
very curious to find out if we can still
cast patrons if we go dark
okay
lots of patronus talk this week and
rightfully so because
actually before i before i talk about
that though i want to talk about
something that
j i saw james uh expect to go pointed
out wizardingworld.com legacy connect
let me see if it has it on this site too
okay they actually worded a little bit
differently here
that is super interesting
[Music]
let me see if i can find the tweet
because they they worded it differently
on
on a tweet that it said like to to
unlock your
it said your house your wand and more
and so i saw james talking about this
like what is this and more
[Music]
what is this and more that they're
talking about you know
oh i can't find it now i'll have to oh
here it is here it is here it is
here it is is this graphic right here
link your harry potter fan club and wb
games accounts for rewards
import your house
wand and more like the only other thing
tied to our account is
our patronus
that's it
i mean unless your name like maybe
they're pulling i guess they can pull
your your name you put your name on
there i forgot about that but like
see i feel like it's not in
because chandler why wouldn't they have
just announced it there like it seems
like it would have made perfect sense to
just
why not just say
i guess because they haven't confirmed
that patronus is in the game yet which i
think
see here we go chat we're going down the
rabbit hole now i think patronus has to
be in the game
i think it has to be in the game because
the mentors are in the game
and there's no way for us to combat
dementors
unless
[Music]
we have a patronus
now it could be as we talked about in
the big live stream with podcast now and
uh expect to go and
benjamin snow and andy reloads we talked
about it could be a
non-corporeal patronus so if you guys
remember from the series like this is
one of those areas where harry was
actually better than hermione there
weren't many
there were not very many but this is one
spot where
he was able to cast a full
corporeal patronus from a very young age
lupin talked about how it was
rare for wizards to be able to cast one
that early but even more rare for them
to be able to cast a corporeal patronus
corporeal is just a big complicated a
big long word that basically just means
it takes the actual form of an animal
rather than just being this sort of like
bluish
glow that wards off to mentors
so taking the form of the animal is even
more difficult to do so we were thinking
okay they could still have a patronus
but it's non-corporeal which could work
i could definitely see that
i can't see them bringing over the
patronus simply because
of all the different anime i mean there
are so many animals on the wizarding
world website if you look at how many
patronus patron patronuses are patroni i
think it's patronus is if you look at
how many are possible
that would be a lot of of programming
work
and then some of them are like a dragon
it's like
come on dude you're gonna have a big
dragon warding off to mentors and then
some people have like uh
a swan or a you know a goose basically
or something some can fly some are real
like somebody said a hedgehog earlier
so it's like man there would be just a
drastically different
animations they'd have to program which
if they did it i mean my jaw would be on
the floor that'd be amazing i think the
more likely scenario is it's either
non-corporeal one or two we all have the
same patronus and they tie it into our
character's backstory
so whatever the backstory of our
character is maybe there's something
significant so like snape for example
remember how his patronus becomes a
a silver doe
[Music]
i wonder if his patronus was always the
books probably talk about this and i
just can't remember
because my gut tells me that it wasn't
always a silver doe
but if that's the case that would mean
your patronus could change
and i realized i didn't even answer your
question christy because you were asking
what if we could can we cast patronus if
we go dark
if you guys remember the dark wizards in
the harry potter series i think the
reason she's asking this is because the
dark wizards could not
they couldn't cast patronus
because you think about the way that you
cast patronus you have to have that like
really happy memory to draw from
now i guess some of them could just draw
from a really for them a happy memory it
might be a really dark
thing but for them it might be a happy
memory
that would be kind of crazy though if
you can't but what if the dementors
the dementors they don't attack you if
you're evil
they're like on your side because i mean
think about it they didn't attack
voldemort because
voldemort was able to dude wouldn't you
love to see the behind the scenes for
that like voldemort negotia how did
voldemort negotiate
with freaking dementors
whatever he did he won them to his side
basically by convince convincing them
that there was going to be so much fear
so much
so many people in pain
that they would they could leave azkaban
oh my gosh dude that
so if you guys didn't see james's video
yet james of expecto go his theory
and i think it makes a lot of sense
is that actually let me pull up the full
pull up the full wallpaper here so you
guys can see this so we've all seen the
standard
and sorry i know i'm getting behind no
comments i'll catch you up here
this is what always happens chat you
guys ask such good questions and we just
we just start going down the rabbit hole
that's what these streams are all about
honestly if this your first time here
this this is just normal this is what we
do
there's not really a huge agenda
i respect james so much he always goes
in with like this detailed agenda and
then chat just inevitably like
he's derailed
very quickly in
all right so let me go into my
folder here of all the
all right so this image right here
james's theory is that this scene that
we're seeing
is basically the evil ending
if you go down the evil path that this
is the ending you would get
this one is the good ending
which we've seen this one right we've
seen this one many many times
nope i'm gonna have to minimize
so you see the differences here this one
we're all familiar with we've seen it a
lot so this is like if you
you know if you uh choose the good side
and you leave the world
in a better place you stop the evil
and then this
is if you go dark
which oh my gosh like look at the
inferior man
by the way it is in theory guys i always
get comments of people saying it's in
inferi no it's it is in theory
uh a lone one isn't infurious i had been
i knew that but i'd forgotten about i
hadn't been uh saying that in my videos
people were calling me out on it
corrected me which i i appreciate the
corrections i do
uh so yeah so alone was it alone one on
its own isn't in furious but then
together they're in fury cause look at
that dude i think what if we are
actually
oh my gosh dude what if we are actually
the one raising these in theory if we go
down the dark path
and then you have the dementors those
dementors do not look like they're
attacking us
they do not
so to answer your question christy what
if you go down the dark path and you
don't need a patronus because the
dementors they're not even concerned
with you they're like fighting on your
side
oh my goodness that would be insane
and these i mean these inferior they
kind of look like they're attacking but
this wizard's like uh whatever i'm not
worried
got the spider over here
this spider looks very different from
the acromantula by the way
the acromantula the hidden acromantula
is still over here on the right side
they didn't take him out but then they
also added this one over here as well
then you got the dragon up here
then you have the thestral here
thestrals
[Music]
and then this one has no thestrals this
one has the owl this one does still have
the
macromantula over here no spider over
here though no inferior no dementors you
do still have the dragon over here too
oh man
[Music]
all right let's get caught up on the
comments here
tonk's patronus changed okay that's
right yes it can change yes
[Music]
go with petronai just because it's silly
[Music]
your dr sherbet paternus is a dragonfly
i did not even realize that was actually
a patronus that is amazing
so you could if they pro if they
if they actually did the ones from
pottermore they would literally have to
pro program in
animations that go from a small
dragonfly
all the way to a full like i assume like
a full-sized dragon like this
that is crazy yes they can also deliver
messages yeah that's another wizard use
that we uh learned of them
welcome welcome to the new subs coming
in there
ernest is a ginger cat my patronus nico
was a on pottermore as a tortoiseshell
cat which
i think i mentioned last week does not
fit me at all i'm highly allergic to
cats actually
so i have since taken additional
patronus tests that are all of the
questions remember how i like to do that
with sorting i did the same thing with
uh
the um
patronus one and i got a dolphin that
time which dolphin has always been one
of my favorite animals i think that's
much more fitting
[Music]
wait knows of sauron saying unwise to
try
[Music]
see this what happens when i get behind
i miss the reference for a lot of the
comments my apologies guys my apologies
uh andrew i did see was asking about
flexibility of the wand so i think
there's a description on wizarding world
for like rigid versus uh
supple
unyielding those sorts of things
[Music]
to mentors i've come to bargain
hey welcome jenny welcome
[Music]
oh wait amore poet is responding to
timothy we have uh harry survived a
killing curse there was no other known
way to survive that difference is that
we have an explanation right right
we don't have any examples of ancient
magic defending against dementors ah so
maybe uh timothy might have been saying
maybe the ancient magic helps us
fight dementors even if we don't learn
expecto patronum because we know you
can't kill a dementor isn't that crazy
like even even expect a patronum is
i mean basically just a shield against
them it just wards them away
i just like the idea of a dementor is uh
man what an what an amazing creation
for like a
an evil creature
like literally they all they do is just
like
feed off of negativity
it's crazy
they would thrive on social media right
oh man
uh bread loaf was asking we can redo it
how so you can delete your wizarding
world account
and then you can just make a new one
using the same email if you if you want
to do that yeah you can just literally
there's like no wait time you can delete
it
create a brand new one and
use the exact same email
dolphin patronus nice yeah i i'm going
with dolphin that's what i tell people
like
i feel like that's my patronus
dude you guys got some cool patronuses
like hippogriffs we've got uh
i saw somebody with the i saw at least
one with a dragon
feathers i agree like
i don't think they would be going that
deep with it
i think it's going to be mostly cosmetic
but
that would be incredible
and like it the thing is it can't lock
you out because that's not how it works
in the wizarding world either you know
even if a wand
is says it's like particularly good at
charm work or something it doesn't mean
that other ones can't end up being
better based on the wizard it just means
that they might lend itself a little bit
better you know make it a little bit
easier so if there was like a small stat
boost oh that'd be so clever right
for like certain spells like based on
your wand if you just get like a little
bit more stat points to start off in
that like it'd just be something minor
you know so people wouldn't be totally
locked out i i love that idea i think
that'd be great
[Music]
uh where can i take the sorting exam
with all the questions
i need to find that gabe
somebody just sent it to me
where did they send this to me
uh i'm trying to remember if it was
discord
i do have a discord by the way i know
that's way late somebody was asking
earlier if i have a discord yeah
i need to add a little uh chat alert for
that too
where did they send me this
maybe it was was it reddit
it was either reddit or discord or
or twitter
because the one that i take in the video
is all of the pottermore questions
but it the visual interface is not that
great
alyssa hey alyssa thank you so much for
the super chat
what is your take on making friends
companions in hogwarts legacy do you
think they will become evil if you
become evil too
oh
see i'm torn about the whole choice
thing and how much impact
we have on the world
because they they made a focus of
updating that faq
to say that look we're not
there's not a morality system
or something like that
but then it's like they've been talking
about how important choice is
[Music]
and so the i mean really the the best
example we have is the one with
sebastian because we've seen a trailer
for that so it's like if we let him cast
crucio
on us
does that affect his path
versus if we if we decide to cast it on
him does that affect
i think oh man
i think lu i think maybe loosely i don't
think it'll be big i think the i think
the companions will have
somewhat of a set path
that they will go down which i hope i'm
wrong i'd love to be wrong in that
okay it wasn't reddit was it discord
where i saw this
oh man if somebody knows it in the chat
let me know
we're trying to find the uh
actually you know what i think i might
have remembered what it is
i think it's
yes i found it
it is wizardmore.
here it is wizardmore.com
sorting hyphen hat
jesse astronomers hat
that is still appearing on amazon i
think it's france and germany but we
have not seen anything in the uh us yet
so i don't know i don't really know what
to tell people on that to be honest with
you let me just double check i haven't
looked at the amazon page in a few days
oh let's see
exclusive
yeah there's nothing about it here
so i don't know hopefully that's one
that they'll answer eventually
oh yeah that's right it's not gonna let
you guys post links
sorry i'll post it in the chat here
that's just a a thing to keep the chat
safe it prevents
people from uh
putting links in there
[Music]
feathers reaffirmed your uh ravenclaw
yeah see the one that i took on the
video that i did it's basically this
exact same thing but it's not as uh
the interface isn't nearly as nice
whoever's in charge of this website they
did a great job making it look like it's
on the wizarding world
and then they also have this extended
patronus quiz so extended patronus
actually i don't know what the
difference
in these are
extended versus full
oh let's just take you
wait what this is on their website too
dude how did they program this
what is the extended okay this is the
one i took
this is the extended one that i took
where
my i get mostly dolphin
nico with another gifted membership dude
nico
how many is that tonight thank you so
much nico
looks like carlos getting that gifted
sub carlos congratulations
make sure you give nico a thanks for uh
getting the gifted sub there
or gifted membership
yeah exactly feathers the quizzes on the
actual
wizarding world site don't use all the
questions it's kind of disappointed like
disappointing i wish they i wish they
would give you an option to take like
the full one
so the patronus one is really
interesting there's like a huge
breakdown of like how
[Music]
how it works and how it's based on
the sets of questions that you get asked
because you only have you only have
three options for everything
i'll take it right now we'll do this one
live
i've already done it many times and
dolphin always rises to the top there
yeah sorry about if if any of you tried
to uh post the links
yeah it just
it just helps you never know what people
might post as i i should start to um
actually i wonder like if i
if i click on feathers name here
i think there's a way that you can like
grant permissions for people to uh post
links
uh it's this website right here if you
just go wizardmore.com professor abbott
it'll get you to it but if you want to
go straight to the sorting hat one
i'll post it here in the chat again
paya says the patronus quiz works in
patterns so you can choose the same
words but yes that's thank you you
worded it much better than i did that's
what i was trying to say
i don't know why it took away your oh
you retracted the message abbot gotcha i
was like wait why did it delete that
message there was nothing wrong with
that but you retracted it all good
uh yes so what paya just said right
there or pf sorry if i'm pronouncing
that wrong the patronus quiz works in
patterns so you can choose the same
words but if they are presented to you
at different times you'll get a
different result
so that's why it's like and here's
another thing about the patronus one the
patronus one is supposed to be like a
feeling thing you're supposed to
you're supposed to just go gut reaction
very quickly
very quickly it's what you're supposed
to do on that one
hey ryan welcome dude
sorry i didn't respond to your first one
there
welcome welcome
is chat dead or am i
yo i don't think i don't think chat's
dead they've been asking lots of good
questions tonight
the patronus quiz dozens of time
depending on the first couple of answers
they give you two more right yes for to
get the rarer ones it takes like
but yeah you're supposed to just react
very very quickly
now i have never done the wizard more
i didn't know they even had
an extended one let's do that
[Music]
do it right here because it looks like
the official
the official wizarding world website
when you do this full patronus quiz
right here
all right
hey djing what's up rare patronus
bristol is like uh dolphin or not
dolphin dolphins the most common um
dragon i know is rare i think
phoenix maybe thestral might be rare
yeah
all right here we go here we go here we
go
oh man that's kind of loud let me uh
you're a wizard
i don't want to mute it but i do want to
let me just turn this down a little bit
i don't want it to be super loud for you
guys
albatross is the most rare one
stallion
every time i've taken the uh the
wizarding world one i've gotten a
different result
but whenever i do this one right here
this extended patronus quiz i get
dolphin at the top every time
all right so you can discover your
patronus as many times as you want this
version includes all questions and it's
not time
dude whoever made this wizard more sight
shout out to
them now feathers one thing that people
have done
is people have now learned the answers
and so they kind of cheat
that's why there's a lot of people with
the elder wand
but i think some people have kind of
peaked and are skewing that because the
elder wand is actually supposed to be
really rare
and
i said the elder one not the older one
a wand made of elder have to be careful
about how i word that
brother got so upset that this was a
rottweiler so this one's different in
that it's not timed i'm personally still
gonna take it as i'm gonna try to react
quickly
and not really think about it too much
like give just give my kind of gut gut
feel reaction
but the one on the wizarding world is
timed and the question will skip if you
don't answer in like it's a pretty
narrow window of time actually
yeah whoever made this site this is
amazing
all right here we go let's do this
relax okay think of your happiest memory
right now with the chat
oh no man happiest memory like birth of
my children getting married
uh i have to say son
leaf blade thorn a leaf
blade and thorn just seemed like i don't
know violent
wait what dream discover dance uh
discover
i was also like kind of wanting to do
dream as well
uh-oh it's trying to form
not yet not yet
you almost pretty already i only
answered three questions
seek protect serve
protect
one more ques
i'm i guess i'm just too i'm too simple
again
shine glitter glow shine
oh wait this one said it was supposed to
include all questions so maybe it's not
actually done i don't know
okay it's not blood or bone
definitely bone
blood freaks me out
i get queasy
just like having blood drawn for
anything sweet
gut reaction gut reaction europe
patronus appears to be very rare
yeah so i think this little pop-up at
the bottom
is not a bright or shadow
i mean when i think about happiest
memory i think bright i don't think
about shadow
a lot of these i'm like 50 50 on like
that i could have went
either way with that
definitely warm i hate being cold
and i am cold a lot
i am very cold all the time my wife is
we are the opposite rough smooth uh
smooth
prowl or preen
play
see because like happiest memories i'm
thinking of my family a lot so
that's influencing all of this stonewood
earth
uh gut reaction is
stone
yeah warm butterbeer would be great
rossi
lead save escape
uh lead
yeah so it looks like the pop-ups happen
automatically even though it's it's
gonna give you all the questions think
feel sense think
and i know i've answered these
differently in the past some of these i
know i have my answers not the same
every time
over under around uh definitely over
yo dylan what's up dude
we uh we had to postpone from tuesday of
this week la oh definitely found
normally we do tuesdays but i had to
bump it back
i had a fantasy football draft on
tuesday so
didn't want to miss a stream for the
week though thank you so much for being
here dylan free or safe free
like that one right there i know the
last time i answered it i answered it
safe
forever
you're so close keep going
by the way if anybody's wondering oh
this is uh
wizardmore.com speak silent speak
this will allow you to take all of the
patronus questions
instead of just the few that pop up when
you do it together or alone together
so that's why i keep saying one more but
i have more i we have more than one
who or why why
gut reaction and happiest memory gut
reaction happiest memory
comfort advise and press uh comfort
it's forming it's for me
so this miguel this is a different uh
version this one does all the questions
no matter what watch listen touch uh
listen
so even though it keeps saying one more
question this one uh because it's
through wizardmore.com
it's gonna do all the questions so
that's why it's taking longer
mind heart spirit spirits
oh does it put you in an infinite loop
oh no
black white gray
uh
black
we'll see if it works for me because i
haven't gotten any duplicates yet
i'm gonna be really mad if i go through
all this
love
if i go through all the questions
yeah i mean trust hope and love they're
all uh those are all pretty positive
things
oh here we go here we go here we go
all right
there we go dude
another cat
oh man i'm telling you i'm not a cat
i'm not a cat
my potter my one on wizarding world is a
tortoiseshell cat
this one says black and white now
here's what's crazy though whenever i do
it
using this right here so this is also
wizard more this is the extended
patronus quiz whenever i do this here i
get it shows dolphin
it shows dolphin
someone's in denial laser i'm totally in
denial because i am like i actually like
cat i don't have anything against cats
but i am i am highly allergic to cats
it is really bad i had a friend in high
school who
who had some cats in her house and i
guess i growing up i'd been around cats
occasionally but it was always outside
it was always outside so it wasn't until
i was at this friend's house in high
school
and
they had cats inside and i just started
like
sneezing my eyes were my eyes were the
worst my eyes were just
super red i started just like watering
like crazy i wear contacts so i drove
home like barely able to see i get home
i have to immediately take out my
contacts and i'm just like
my eyes are just on fire
and
i mean i was petting the cat but it
wasn't like you know i didn't have the
cat right in my face or anything
and so then i i learned then like i stay
far away from cats well then years later
my wife and i were to a different friend
different friends house
and they had actually put their cats
away they were in a different room
and just from like we were we were like
uh a bunch of people were sitting on the
couch and then we were kind of sitting
in the floor
in front of the couch and so i had my
hands like behind me on the floor
and so just from like the cat hair
that was in the floor
i started my i started watering again i
started sneezing again i got home we got
in the car i had to
take out my contacts when we got home
again now the patronus it's not a real
cat it doesn't take the physical
form of an actual cat so i don't think i
have to worry about the allergies
but it just it just surprises me that it
uh
that's the second time i've gotten a cat
that's funny though man
yeah dylan rocking the new emoji man i'm
so pumped about the new emoji
jason says what if yours was cerberus
what kind of reaction would that be oh
dude i think servers would be pretty
cool
i was hoping to be dolphin because
that's what i get whenever i do this
extended one
i get a dolphin
but as uh as as pio was talking about
earlier it's like it's kind of based on
the patterns
so i don't know that this is an accurate
let's try to answer let's see if i can
answer the exact same thing so i'm
pretty sure i did shine
this one will go through a lot faster
i'm pretty sure i did discover i almost
did dream but i did discover i
definitely did leaf there
i did protect
i did sun
i did sweet i did improve
i did smooth i did warm
i did bright i did bone
i said stone i said
i think i said lead i almost said save
i think i said
think here i said over
yo dealing with the two months uh
hey thanks so much dylan welcome
remember to hit that like button yeah
thank you so much fuzz ball
10 30 just got a gift it's up nico with
another gifted sub
nico dude thank you so much going crazy
with the gifted subs
going crazy with the gifted subs thank
you so much
and uh congrats fuzzball on getting that
gifted uh membership there
i definitely said play on that one i
said found i said speak i said together
i said forever
i said
why i said
i think i said free this time
no dragon for me look at that dude
seven percent
uh i definitely said love i said listen
i said black i said comfort
i said spirit
i don't think i
i don't remember getting this one but i
would definitely have picked awake
i would have said create yeah i don't
think we got these high or deep i would
say hi
ripple or wave
ripple
sharp or sleek i would say
sleek frost or dew frost
charm or jinx charm
glory ooh myth or legend a legend
enchant
eternal those would be my
i promise i got dolphin before
i guess my other option could have been
red squirrel right there
my other option could have been red
squirrel it's fate it's like
oh the dolphin
okay i'm trying to think
what i answered differently
because i promise you guys i did it like
two or three times and i got dolphin
i think i may have said save one time
oh that that was it
that was literally it right there
so on the one that said
lead save or escape
i feel like i i answer save a lot too
then i would get so i have gotten the
dapl gray mare before too
and then i've also like i said dolphin
i'm choosing dolphin
confirmed cat
cat confirmed for retro regulator
patronus
oh man now like can you guys imagine
when when i play hogwarts legacy if the
patronus is in the game
when that moment comes and i'm like
i don't know
i don't know what to pick
oh camera not that many gryffindors well
are you talking about you probably
talking about the pole
yeah the gryffindors did not fare well
in the poll
so we asked which common room tour were
you most impressed by
13 percent
gryffindor is coming in dead last next
is hufflepuff at 24. next is slytherin
at 30 and then ravenclaw's coming out on
top at 33 i'm gonna go ahead and end
that poll there
thank you guys anybody who voted in the
poll
yeah if i
right demonic right but they did say
that
bringing things over is optional
so
templar just didn't get a dolphin first
time i got a tiny owl
see the patronus one i feel like it's
not like sorting like i feel like the
sorting
if you take that a couple times and you
keep getting the same thing and you
don't think you're that you're
you're just lying to yourself
the patronus one though it's so like
it's based on how you feel like at a
given moment
because there's you're not even really
answering questions like it definitely
doesn't even really give you a prompt
it's just like
pick one of these three words and you're
supposed to be thinking about your your
most uh
your happiest memories and then you're
supposed to be reacting with with gut
feel
so
that one i mean that changes for me
based on the day
see i feel like i have to stick with
dolphin because uh
aj draws who did the little um
you guys haven't seen my
my twitter profile picture right here
aj did a drawing of a bunch of the
hogwarts legacy
slash harry potter youtube creators and
so they reached out and asked me on
patronus before they made this and i
said dolphin so the full picture of this
has me like
casting the dolphin patronus so
that's what i'm sticking with now
come on chat so somebody was saying
there's another one patronus quiz
replica interesting
i'm hesitating i don't know if i wanna i
don't know if i wanna do another one
oh my gosh
let's do it
it is a lot shorter though
let's do it why not let's just it'll
it'll be
it'll be humorous no matter what
but see now it when i see that save i'm
picking the save one
i've got a big save this time
i'm not going to pick lead because lead
is what gets me the cat apparently
oh this one might not be working i keep
getting kind of like an endless refresh
here
oh that might be the one that feathers
was talking about that just keeps
let's try it again patronus quiz replica
yeah something's going on with that one
but these two work the extended patronus
quiz and the full patronus quiz
man i haven't taken the over morning
quiz in a while what house did i get for
ilvermorny
oh man i think for ilvermorny i got
the uh thunder one i believe
[Music]
yeah i'm pretty sure i got thunderbird
which which i think fits for me yeah
i like how these are tied to soul mind
body and heart
[Music]
ah that one doesn't work gotcha
dylan you're not answering honestly like
don't you feel like the patronus answers
can change for you though i mean in all
seriousness because it's like
it doesn't tell you how you're supposed
to it's just like
what do you feel
[Music]
among these three words
it's it's it's strange
oh an orca patronus that's pretty cool
i like that a lot
people are really talented right whoever
made that
is pretty awesome
in the release trailer we can't see the
thestral yeah you're right skye like in
the first uh
yeah
so wonder if we see a death
early in our days at hogwarts
oh
i think a lot of people kind of assumed
the death would happen before
now there's also that whole thing when
it's like
it's not even necessarily just when
you've seen death
but more that you like you've
experienced death like you you fully
comprehend it so maybe it's like fresh
in the character's mind
so that's why they don't see them when
they first arrive
pulling the carriage
[Music]
let's see we watched all of the tours
except for
i don't think we played ravenclaws
tonight
[Music]
you know what i'm going to slow it down
too
let's watch it at .25
means you find comfort and balance
appreciate the mysterious and unknown
and love reveling okay that's a little i
think that's more accurate demonic than
the uh the tortoise shell cat
whatever it said for the tortoise shell
cat i was just like
that's not me at all that
that's not me at all okay so i'll be on
board a little bit more with the black
and white cat
poppy what did you guys do to poppy
starbucks patronus wait what is the
starbucks patronus
nico with five gifted memberships nico
oh my goodness dude
relax nico relax
templar demonic sky danielle tj all
getting a gifted membership right there
from nico
dude nico showing all kinds of love
tonight nico thank you so much
it'll pop up here in a second i saw it
in the chat before it actually popped up
on the
stream there it goes
welcome to gryffindor oh i need to turn
the audio back up too i had turned it
down for the patronus
quiz
[Music]
how are you
welcome to yeah you guys should have the
uh the emotes now
emotes emoji whatever you call them
these right
here
and honestly like we're gonna unlock
more we're gonna unlock more very soon
so
the artist who did these
how are you
i already have more ideas for more like
i kind of want to do a voldemort one
that is uh laughing
because we got like the angry voldemort
how are you
welcome to i think it would be hilarious
if we had a laughing voldemort too
[Music]
be a member someday hey amore poet you
you know you know how i feel
never never feel obligated guys to
support through money honestly you
i truly mean it man like the
if you guys didn't see my tweet today
somebody left a comment
let me actually uh
i'll pull it up here
this right here so this is a comment on
one of my videos today had a rather
trying day at work today so to come home
and have a detailed breakdown of the
ravenclaw common room my one true
hogwarts house waiting for me is a
blessing thank you red dragon tour like
seriously guys
showing love man with the likes with the
shares
and then comments like this like that's
what it's all about man that's what it's
all about
[Music]
yeah right i yeah i feel you christy
things are not cheap right now
things are not cheap in this in this
world
and seem to be going up you know
hopefully inflation's finally starting
to
slow down a bit but
yeah it's been crazy
i mean just like full transparency with
you guys like this
i think most of you probably know this
from the vibe you've heard from the way
i talk like this is what i it's what i
want to do man this is what i
i want to be doing this full time with
you guys like
making videos making more videos doing
date like
i don't know if it'd be every day but
like if this was my full-time gig i'd be
doing like
at least three times a week streams four
times a week streams
more videos maybe not even more videos
higher quality videos i think i'd have a
lot more time to work on it but
like with the environment with
everything being the way it is right now
in the world it's like you know
it's kind of scary to like walk away
from a uh
a regular
full-time income
uh
even when the youtube channel is doing
well because the channel is doing really
well thanks to you guys man it's amazing
it's awesome but yeah that's my that's
my dream that's my dream
is to one day uh one day get there so
we'll see how it goes shadow at 1.75
speed trying to catch up nice
yeah that's what i always do on james's
uh
expecto goes streams as well two games
to play gotta go have a great rest of
your day hey two games thanks so much
for hanging out and thank you for that
membership as well
wolf trooper oh man we got another
slytherin another slytherin with the
gifted
oh man we got we got lots of slytherins
in here we do i feel like slytherin and
ravenclaw are probably the most vocal
i think
it's been an hour already
it's been uh we started 8 30. it's
almost been two hours here
almost been going for two hours
how many ravenclaws in the house there's
a lot of ravenclaws miguel
a lot of ravenclaws hey exactly christy
just being here is a huge support
still live yeah yeah still live we've
only been live for about two hours
almost two hours anyway ilvermorny got
horn snake interesting
hogwarts exam i get hufflepuff and
ravenclaw
well horn snake it's funny they don't
all have a direct
analog to the hogwarts house there's
some slight differences so like i think
a lot of times people think horn serpent
as being the uh
like slytherin
but
horn serpent is like for the mind so
focusing on the scholar so that one
would probably be a little bit closer to
ravenclaw really
but then these like the other three i
don't feel like they really have a
direct comparison to the hogwarts houses
because i mean you maybe you think of
like you might think of gryffindor as a
warrior but then he i also feel like
he's more heart
maybe like hufflepuff as an adventurer
yeah i don't feel like there's a direct
comparison which i like i like that it's
not clearly just yeah this is gryffindor
this is hufflepuff ravenclaw i like that
they're a little bit different i think
that's good
but yeah so horn serpent focuses on the
on the mind
that's a super welcome back good to see
you here can see you getting there hey i
appreciate it that's the dream
that's the dream we're working to it
panda starting to think it's multiple
years now because of the name legacy
also so much stuff with merlin morgana
goblin rebellion dark wizards ancient
magic dragons there's a lot no doubt
no doubt there's a lot
see here's the thing with the timing
though with the time
it's all about how they structure the
time and so here's what i mean by that
you could have a 40 hour game
that could be three years or it could be
one year and it's like
strictly just based on how they
structure things like how fast time
passes
jake hey jake appreciate you being here
have a good one jake thanks for stopping
by so it's it's all about how they have
it set up
in terms of how the seasons pass how the
day night cycle works all of that will
impact
how long the game is so honestly like
i've
as much as i like the discussion of like
is it gonna be more than one year really
because
being more than one year would be
incredible when you think about the
implications of uh
like dumbledore being if we get to year
three
or year seven for us
jake with a super chat on the way out as
well good talking to you as well jake
and always appreciate your support
have a good one have a good one
hufflepuffs get me quiet jay ross he
says yeah indeed there we go we got some
gryffindor's representing
ah fuzzball was a gifted uh member
fuzzball got the gryffindor
slytherin strong the three lesser houses
could learn a lot
[Music]
zenith or uh i'm zynthe zynthix gotta
head out 4 13 4 13 oh my gosh
well have a great rest of your morning
xentix thank you for stopping by and
hanging out
[Music]
feathers do i think avalanches create
i've never thought about that i'm gonna
say no because there's just so much to
actually
actually i'm gonna say yes but i think
only
only the ancient magic stuff
and looks like mr seven digit just said
it yeah
i think with the ancient magic stuff
i think that will be tied into
unique things that they've done although
we've kind of seen the lightning before
we've seen grindelwald do that and then
voldemort did it
as well
you guys catch the snitch right here
right
there
it also shows up briefly in a another
moment of this trailer
[Music]
demonic none of those are slytherin i'd
never go to ilvermoria
oh that's funny
we'll slow this one down too
[Music]
catholic watching from college two
minutes before class
two minutes before class at this hour
it must be early morning where you are
thank you for showing show and support
hanging out in the stream
arkham knight left for like an hour glad
to see he's still here yeah we're still
going
it's like it's you guys the chat man you
guys ask such good questions
it just keeps things flowing nice and uh
nice and easy
plumbed wait
oh my gosh i love that name plum dog
millionaire subscribe to the channel
slumdog millionaire great movie by the
way if you've never seen it
love that movie
gotta be 60 to 80 hours because of how
big it is okay
i haven't dropped the whole sources
thing in a while
but
for those of you who follow the channel
for a while you know that i
broke the story on quidditch not being
in the game way before this
it was actually confirmed
so
i was told that by two people behind the
scenes
that's when i reported on it
one of the people who told me about
quidditch
i reached out to them again after this
whole uh
reveal of the common rooms and said
basically like you all have to be super
pumped
about this
and i'm i'm paraphrasing here i'm
paraphrasing
but their response was something to the
effect of you ain't seen nothing yet
that's basically what they said
and i was just like
excuse me
think about that you guys think about
that so like
even with what we've seen so far as as
excited as we are with the common rooms
again that's not their exact words i'm
i'm paraphrasing but it was essentially
their their meaning to me
was
you ain't seen nothing yet and i'm just
like oh my gosh you got to be kidding me
man you got to be kidding me because
this is the stuff i love dude like
chandler wood he
i love chandler he downplayed this
beforehand he's like i want to set you
know the expectations which i appreciate
him doing that
because people were asking like what can
we expect at the auto not the autodesk
at the uh back to hogwarts
because a lot of people were talking
about
you know well this is gonna be a little
bit for more of a it's a different
audience than gamescom this is more for
harry potter look at the chess set
moving by the way look at that look at
the piece moving
we gotta be able to play right we got to
be able to play dude
but um anytime chandler sets the
expectations low i'm going to be like
okay
something big is something big is going
to happen
something big is going to happen i want
to put up another poll question here
dealing with the 10
super chat
oh my god dude dylan always showing love
in the chat dylan thank you so much man
thank you so much dude very much
appreciated
guys shout out to dylan in the chat
dylan a uh channel member here supporter
of the channel for a while i see dylan
hanging out and
all the hogwarts like
expect a go podcast now i see dylan
everywhere dylan always showing love
thank you so much i'm gonna put up a new
poll i asked this on the
um on my youtube community page too but
i'll ask it to you guys as well because
you guys are the ones here for the live
stream so
long long ago before i did the whole
youtube thing i streamed on twitch
fairly regularly
um
but frankly to be honest with you guys
didn't have a lot of success didn't
didn't really get very many people
checking out the streams
um so this is like a
this is awesome this is a refreshing
change to have so many hanging out for
just these little discussions but i want
to get back into streaming games again
too not to replace this but in addition
to this it would probably just be i
don't know one night a week at first
because as i've already mentioned with
time and everything it'd be you know i
don't want to bite off more than i can
chew which is what happened before and
where i basically had to stop streaming
all together
but i want to know
i got a couple of games that i'm really
wanting to play that i think would be
fun to play on stream so that's what i'm
going to ask in the poll here so which
of these games now if you don't like any
of these games that's totally fine just
you don't have to vote you could just
don't worry about it
but if there's one of these games that
you're like oh man i'd love to watch i
would love to show up in a live stream
and watch retro play through that game
then go ahead and vote and let me know
so which of these games would you most
um which of these games how do i word
this
which of these games would you be most
interested
in watching
me live stream now before you guys
because whenever i post this on the
community page everybody's like harry
potter harry potter hogwarts like his
hogwarts i'm like
i i know that guys i've got
i've got um
let's plays of harry potter games on the
channel more of them actively going up
and of course we're going to do a ton of
hogwarts legacy stuff this is in
addition to those things
so
first option is god of war 2018 which i
have already played
but i am really interested in possibly
replaying that another one is ghost of
tsushima
which i have started playing
oh no darn it i'm gonna have to end the
poll
i didn't put a i didn't put enough
in the poll
oh my gosh you guys voted so quick i got
12 votes that fast
levi you gotta head out hey levi thanks
for hanging out
i didn't get to add all my options hold
on
which of these games would you
be most stop stop
it's done it's over
would you be most interested
in watching me live stream
okay so god of war
2018 version
ghost of
sushima i think i pronounced that okay
add option that's what i want to do now
and it looks like we can only add
yeah you can only add four options so
the other one i've really been thinking
about playing through is pokemon legends
of arceus
and then this one's an old one but i've
heard so many good things xenoblade
chronicles
definitive
uh
i'll just say xenoblade chronicles i
don't need to say definitive edition
okay gotta work go sushima pokemon
legends of arceus
and then xenoblade chronicles all right
boom go now you can vote all right
and we got another super chat coming in
there
yo kartik with the super chat
karthik thank you so much for the super
chat there
no i don't want to close okay there we
go
all right oh you didn't even have a
question karthik just uh showing some
love and support thank you so much
karthik
lionel says cult of the lamb
ghost is so good once yeah i mean
honestly ghost is a game that i
i love i loved everything i played
but i just it's been so long now since i
i dropped off i would need to go in and
relearn everything so at this point i'd
just be better off restarting the game
i'd just be better off restarting the
game and so i think it'd be fun to
stream that one especially since that uh
took some inspiration from or hogwarts
legacy took some inspiration from
ghost of tsushima
nico luigi's mansion three better be on
the pole yeah nico was there there
during the twitch days man
during the twitch days of us streaming
to like five people
yeah tom you're right tom i've noticed
that and i've also noticed
way more of like a global reach
on youtube
which i mean i'm sure twitch has a
global reach too but like
every stream that it's like there's
people from like germany there's people
from the uk there's people from there
was somebody in here from japan
blows my mind
[Music]
oh i didn't include persona 5 ryan i
yeah i had to take one off because uh
that's another one that is really um
i really need to play as well i own it
and i i started it
i probably should have put that instead
of pokemon but we'll see i don't know
you guys might love pokemon i'll see
what poll says here
[Music]
uh what you stream on youtube or
catholic might be saying would i stream
on youtube
that what do you guys think like
[Music]
because i'm kind of torn like
clearly the live show this sort of talk
show
like youtube is the home for that
youtube is the home but if i'm streaming
like just a game would you guys rather
see it here would you guys rather see it
on twitch do you have a preference
or do you not i mean i think most people
are like yeah what i can watch you
either place
which is good i love hearing that
see look there we go puerto rico spain
australia
let's go man
[Music]
i would choose persona yeah i should put
persona instead of pokemon
[Music]
crystal can we show oh dude reflex
my backlog you guys it's so great my
backlog is ridiculous right now it
really is
um
spiderman miles morales
i need to replay that one too
i need to replay not replay i've never
played through that one i played through
spider-man
but i haven't re i haven't played miles
morales
oh dude
okay we'll get to this first one i need
to make a list
i'm gonna do that right now
all right so just like
you guys are giving me ideas but just
like in no particular order
these are some games that i either never
got around to finishing
in the case of god of war i kind of just
want to replay it before ragnarok or a
wizard harry so we had god of war
my backlog all right persona 5 which
i've started never beaten
and i'm ashamed to admit this guys
because like when i was when i was young
pretty much until i had kids
like
i i did not start games
i didn't i oh what am i trying to say i
always finish my games
like
i would i would always play a game
through to the end
almost almost always
and then if i like the game i always
want to go through and go back and get
like all the trophies love doing the
platinum trophy thing
so
i'm pretty sure i got the platinum
trophy in eldon ring already like that's
one that like that's the last that might
be the last game that i beat
i think it is because that was just i
was all in on that uh but persona 5 i'm
ashamed to say and i'm a huge fan of
persona 4. so i started persona 5 didn't
beat it um
that's one i want to have on my list
xenoblade
pokemon
arceus
uh let's see what other one did we say
spider-man
miles morales
hey kieran with a 20 super chat
kieran thank you so much
man you guys are just like
showing crazy love tonight
very much appreciated
thanks for doing what you do love
watching these helps get away when the
days get long excited keep watching the
videos current thank you so much man i
i'm telling you dude like the comments
today have just been
really incredible so thank you so much
for the super chat showing the love that
way but
even more just like being here and
supporting the stream and sharing those
kind words
somebody was wanting to see the
hufflepuff common room again so we'll
have it there oh my gosh miguel
that might be the one i'm most ashamed
to admit
is that i have not beaten red dead two
i have not beaten red dead two
i'm telling you guys the parents know
the parents out there will understand
oh man like
well and i don't say this to get
i'm not like uh i'm not saying this to
get sympathy or anything but like doing
the youtube stuff
like a lot of that i've had to sacrifice
a lot of game time don't feel sorry for
me i love doing the youtube stuff
and you know there's
money coming in from doing that so i i
accept that and i'm i'm fine with that
but
putting more effort into that it does it
does hit somewhere and so
you know i don't want to cut out on
family time so it's like games are
really
but see like if i stream if i start
streaming again that's like that's
content for the channel
and also
i'm getting to do something i love hang
out play video games so somebody said
would i do it on a second channel i
don't think so
i think i would if i do um if i do live
stream on youtube which we might
experiment uh i think some of you let me
try to go back here somebody's on the
moon lionel's actually on the moon
oh we got canada here as well demonic
says i can watch you on either have a
prime sub with your name on retro yo
let's go demonic that's right if you
guys have amazon prime you can subscribe
for free on twitch
persona or pokemon i would watch jp says
can watch you on either oh wait that was
demonic uh dylan in detroit let's go
dylan also said would watch me on either
place wolf trooper said youtube
uh skye said youtube because i just got
a gifted membership here panda says
youtube feathers try not to do twitch
that's just me
that's gonna see
[Music]
jason tend to follow more on youtube can
watch on twitch as well
i know tom i know i really want to play
it
too jp just made it sure to follow hey
thank you jp yeah
make a straw poll and pin it so we get
more options
it only lets me do uh
here in the uh like in the live stream
it limits you to four options for some
reason but
if you go to our youtube community page
so
right
oh yeah i totally forgot we were looking
at the autodesk thing
if you go to the youtube page so this is
like the main channel and if you go to
uh community
i just posted this oh my gosh dude ghost
of sushima god of war neck and neck
right now this is with 2 000 plus votes
you guys
not wow i'm surprised persona isn't
higher pokemon though making a run
xenoblade no love for cena blade
dude god of war and ghost to sushima 20.
so you guys can vote there too feel free
to vote twice and also this one you can
comment on so
you can leave a comment there and and
i'll do more of these like i just want
to like
i just for this for when we started i
really want to pick a game that you guys
would um
that you know i know people would be
interested in because i've never i've
never done a stream like that on youtube
i'd be curious to see how
how it would go you know
and i would still be you know
interacting with chat and things but
it's it's a different vibe
i'm sure many of you have watched games
being live stream before it's it's a
different vibe because i mean you know
there's a lot more going on
it's not just about the the chat
interaction
[Music]
i feel you laser too many hills wait
what did you say about
i don't know i missed lasers comment
about uh hills or something
twitch has been busted constantly
rebuffering and freezing oh yikes
oh i feel you okay that's what you were
referring to persona persona is very
long
how many platinums oh my gosh we'll have
to we'll check it here in a second
elder ring plot yeah dude i was so into
elden ring
so into elden ring
hey vince you have a good night as well
appreciate you hanging out
gabe says miles morales
uh king immersive features activities do
you think there will be you mean like uh
like extracurricular like so like uh
wizard chess things like that
[Music]
that's true mine
you guys are like trying to sway me on
the miles morale miles morales is
shorter that's true man like
almost all these are very long games
except for miles morales
that might be a good one to start with
just because it is shorter that's a good
point
that'd be funny though if i actually
ended up doing one that wasn't even in
the poll
red dead is a super long game
[Music]
hey wizardphd wait was your phd hanging
out
oh you talk about how she plays yeah oh
and that's another game i want to play
is uh the lego harry potter games i do
she was playing the lego harry potter
games the other day
and i'm like yep i have uh
i have those too
and i need to i'd love to stream them
and play through them again
[Music]
nobody played santa blade right
majestic omen let's go
as a dad oh that's a good point too god
of war could be the play and see it'd be
a good time for god of war right before
the uh
or before the new game
but you guys make a good point i might
be able to finish miles morales
and then still get in god of war
if i like if i started it
let's see what are we in we're in like
we're still early september and god of
war is
mid-november
even if i just did like
oh man i don't know god of war is pretty
long i might have to go for
those streams would definitely be longer
i'll say that dylan with another 10
super chat dylan says gotta go with
miles morales
[Music]
dylan thank you so much
never spend money on biles morales let
alone play it
what
what are you talking about demonic
so uh feather set just started playing
lego harry potter again
i think they're the best harry potter
games i do
i really do
i think they are the best harry potter
games
[Music]
sky gotta go 3 a.m haven't had an hour
sleep oh my gosh skye you better get
some sleep
have a good night thanks for stopping by
and glad you got the uh
one of those gifted memberships
don't even know what miles morales is oh
i'm worried so miles morales is um
you're a wizard harry
so in the comics miles morales is a new
character
you're a wizard harry oh let's see we
need to see him uh he's also in the uh
oh what's the movie
into the spider verse
amazing movie
majestic omen with a super chat
thank you so much for the five dollars
keep rocking retro
majestic thank you so much for showing
the love and support
appreciate you being here and appreciate
you showing love to the channel um
[Music]
crazy with the love tonight you guys
yeah miles morales is awesome and uh so
the story of miles morales is like
i don't want to ruin it if you haven't
seen it
but it's really interesting one how
how he kind of becomes a version of
spider-man
created antoine 2011 well new in the
sense that
well the video game is new
the miles around this video game is new
so he's not really a new character but i
i would say into the mainstream
really into the spider verse was kind of
uh his first big like
foray into the mainstream
yeah miles morales is a character's been
around for a while but what i love about
miles morales story is like
he's like
he's like we would be if there was a
superhero in our world so it's like he
like he he's in the world of spider-man
he knows spider-man
looks up to spider-man as a hero
so it's just it's super interesting how
they uh
how they set it up
if so
what
okay there's gotta be a story here
there's gotta be a story from demonic
about uh cause this is like a very uh
well-reviewed
well-reviewed game
[Music]
so yeah into the spider verse gives you
a good uh
if you've never seen that
yeah considering how long peter parker's
been around um into
actually getting ready to come out when
is the second into the spider verse
releasing
[Music]
uh
date
[Music]
release date delayed no
i anticipate had been anticipated or
expected to hit cinemas later this year
in october however sony's now revealed
oh man june 2023 darn it
if you haven't seen the first one though
this movie is awesome
[Music]
awesome animated movie
i watched it with my eight-year-old he
he loved it too
but then the uh the games that insomniac
made they have like a filter
oh dude that's sick
they have a filter to make them look
like the into the spider verse like even
even lowering the frame rate which i
know it's like lower frame rates what
but even just to test it out it looks so
cool
that's some pretty cool wallpaper right
there
so yeah i don't want to ruin the story
because it is a it's a really fun story
if you guys get a chance to check it out
where can you watch it uh it was on
netflix for a while
let's see
where can you
stream into the spider-verse
uh let's see netflix uh enter the
spider-man oh this is from 2020.
[Music]
somebody in the chat might know
[Music]
[Music]
weirder stream decider
yeah i know it was definitely on netflix
for a while but i think they might have
taken it off there now
oh yeah somebody asked about difficulty
for hogwarts legacy yeah dave difficulty
settings are confirmed yep
[Music]
super fun to play in the into the
spider-verse mode yeah like even if it's
just like
something to test out i think it
i i thought it looked awesome when i was
messing around with it
it may be disney plus but i know disney
plus doesn't have the
the the main spider-man movies yet
fx now i think always go to imdb to
check travis says ah nice
let's see here
[Music]
i'm gonna refresh this see if you guys
have went and affected this poll yet oh
you guys somebody did anyway god of war
by one percent right now oh that is so
close
[Music]
um imdb so does imdb have like a where
is it
streaming
[Music]
let's see here let's see
oh yeah there you go watch on fx now
more watch options
prior oh so prime video you can rent it
for 2.99
we're just honestly it's probably pretty
cheap to just buy it out right now too
bet you could get it on sale
on prime oh nice that'd be even better
if it's on prime
just watch
dude you guys are telling me about
oh dude i remember this site
obviously i didn't remember it well
enough because i
i guess i didn't remember to pull it up
here
fubo tv streaming oh here we go free
ah
nowhere free right now i guess
yeah it looks like amazon voodoo you can
rent it for 2.99
oh wait you can buy it for
four dollars spectrum on demand
so it looks like it's still about 15
bucks most places if you want to buy it
or rent it for a couple bucks
yeah it's got it's got fubo on here it
doesn't show up as free for some reason
but
poppy oh
you guys going on poppy right now
oh no is this another uh
is this something else to
get under james's uh
get under james's skin
with the poppy hate
hey majestic thank you for stopping by
have a good night
puppy tom riddle look like a choir boy
oh man you guys
all right so let's try i
i i want to make sure we've recapped all
the hogwarts legacy news
so
one thing i want to confirm for you guys
that they they confirmed is that so
the uh house robes
which everybody is like really digging
these house-themed robes they have
confirmed that you will unlock all of
them
for your account so a lot of people were
worried about multiple playthroughs like
you know if you play through as a
ravenclaw and then you go back and play
through as a gryffindor what about the
house robes well
the way they're implementing it is
actually pretty cool too it's like
it is one item so you'll get the house
fanatic robe
and then when you replay as a different
house
it will automatically show the correct
house which i think makes perfect sense
it's not like you need to manage four of
them it's not like you need to redo
anything when you when you play again as
the new house
it is
all gonna be automatic which i think is
a perfect way of doing it
um bring your wizarding world identity
into the game
most of you here have probably already
done this connect now it's very easy to
do very simple to set up and it does not
lock you into anything
a lot of people were worried about that
asking chandler about that what if i
don't like my uh wand what if i don't
like my house he's like doesn't like you
into anything you might as well go ahead
and do it though just for the free and
game rewards
and then they also give you a uh
wallpaper too
[Music]
and then there's something oh yeah the
the skull beak mask that's something
else that you get
so that was a huge announcement at the
uh
at the back to hogwarts event then they
also had all of the common room reveals
that was that was the other big one
which if you guys haven't seen yet i am
doing uh full breakdowns over on my
channel
so
i've done uh slytherin was first then we
did gryffindor then we did ravenclaw and
then up next would be hufflepuff after
that we'll probably do a
there might be two more follow-up videos
after that because i want to do like a
tier list ranking
and then i want to do like a secrets and
and hidden details of all of them so if
people just want to watch like one video
and it would be like a very highly
edited like quick quick pace video
because these these are steadily getting
longer like we got nine minutes we got
14 minutes we got 16 minutes that was
not by design i did not intend to do
that that's just kind of how it uh how
it's been happening
new mask makes me i want to go dark
oh i've seen i've seen the images
demonic i have
i think benjamin snow played a role in
uh
some of the poppy slander going on
nico stop this madness
i know right chandler constantly having
to answer the same questions
[Music]
it's funny
totally dark on the first playthrough
i mean honestly given everything they've
shown like dark seems like it's gonna be
way more fun
especially if you get
dude if they have like any form of
necromancy like if you have dementors
fighting on your side if you having fury
fighting on your side going down the
dark path
like what are they possibly going to
have on the good side maybe maybe have
like
other magical creatures that fight for
you if you're on the good side dude what
if the dragon
yo
james is all about merlin and his
connection to the dragon what if the
what if you get the dragon to fight for
you if you're on the good side
that's like that would help balance i
think that would help balance out
because you got to give the good guys
something cool too right
[Music]
hoping for a gray area jp set yeah i
hope so too jp
i hope so too
[Music]
i feel bad quite dark there's never it's
never fun not at any stretch of the word
amore poet is like i'm full
paragon on the light side here
dude an inferior dragon
oh man
right j rossi yeah i could see that too
don't give me dragon i'll go dragon
rider style on this game
yeah like i was just i'm just trying to
think so what are some things that could
balance out
give the good guys some cool things too
patronus would be one because let's say
we're we're not going to get avodah
cadaver we're not going to get the
unforgivables
maybe you have better stealth
if you go on the good side
um let's see you'd have patronus
maybe they could tie you into the
if you're like helping merlin and
helping helping him preserve this
ancient magic
then maybe the dragon is like loyal to
you
in some way so the dragon fights on your
side maybe you have other other magical
creatures fighting on your side too that
was one of the very first hogwarts
legacy theory videos i did
even based just on the one trailer we
had is how
crucial of a role i think the magical
creatures are going to play i think
they're going to play a major major part
um
so yeah that might be an interesting way
they they're helping you the knights of
hogwarts maybe maybe we get the knights
of hogwarts going on
the ac lightning the only good
alternative right for robotic cadaver
but i mean that's killing
that's killing too
then again also like setting someone on
fire
with incendio i assume we're all gonna
have access to that spell
stealth should be an evil side per
account that we can break in dogs mean
cool to see the dead coming out of the
ground fighting for you oh my gosh
if they if they actually have where you
can
somehow control the inferior
dude
dude
maybe beast with better skills yeah that
could be
harry went through
expelliarmus's go-to spell
the go-to spell for harry potter
talk to dragons a cool nod to harry talk
to snakes yeah i like that i like that
in harry potter magic awaken if you use
the dark spells enough you can't use
some of the good cards
interesting
that's interesting there maybe better
healing buffs jay rossi says yeah i
didn't think about that it's true
[Music]
having me thinks there's not that much
merlin in the game
the other half is
totally sold by james
well
i mean
to james's point like
we at least have confirmation
that merlin like
merlin is in the game in the form of
like the spells that he's the uh not
spells the puzzles that he's left behind
does he play a major role in the story
that
i think is
the big question you know
the trailer that the dark arts trailer
that they showed focused heavily on
salazar slytherin but again that
remember what chandler said that was
just a side quest
that was just a side mission
so maybe the side missions like for each
companion really explore the founders
but then there's
a merlin a morgana some other character
that the main like core story
oh yeah flopindo dude flupindo
it's
imagine if flopindo is like
the final spell you unlock on the good
path
and it's just like this
immensely powerful finisher
oh goodness
[Music]
i'm working on a flopindo video by the
way to tease some upcoming videos it's a
shorter one but it's like a fun kind of
look back at the history of flopindo and
its use in the in the video games
because i know how how much everybody
loves that spells like that would be fun
spongeify for the good path
join forces with ranroc we'll see that
remains to be seen because the whole
goblin situation it's going to be
interesting to see how it's presented
because
goblins and wizards in that whole
conflict neither side is without
fault
they both have some things that they are
wrong about
and so
we're jumping into an 1890s wizarding
world that was probably a lot more even
more harsh on the goblins than they were
in harry potter's day
and so it's like
goblins definitely deserved more rights
than the wizards were giving them but
also like goblins weren't human you know
they have a good they have a high
intelligence but there's also
certain parts of just their nature as
i guess they are still technically
considered magical beasts because
or are they not i'm trying to remember i
used i was researching some stuff a few
weeks ago and had my fantastic beast
book right beside me but basically i
mean they're not humans they're not
humans so there are some things just in
their nature that
that are different that you know you
have to consider
that's different from humans but but it
is it's one of those conflicts like
where where the goblins have some points
you know
so
i i am really curious to see how it's
presented and if there's a level of
grayness to it
i hope so i hope it's not a clear black
and white
just like
goblins are bad in this game and if you
side with evil you work with the goblins
which i don't think it is because we see
that shot in in one of the trailers
where
we're also talking to that goblin in the
hog's head a different uh goblin
not
ran rock but a different goblin
[Music]
what a montage of me doing a flipping
only playthrough
impedimenta i don't think it's
confirmed
i don't think it's confirmed
and then somebody uh i don't even know
what that spell is that dylan just
mentioned there
melafors
[Music]
the jinx
oh
it's the pumpkin head jinx
of course
the pumpkin head jinx
no matter where harry went within the
castle the sole topic of conversation
was dumbledore's flight and though some
of the details may have gone awry in the
retelling harry overheard one second
year girl assuring another that fudge
was now lying in saint mungos with a
pumpkin for a head it was surprising how
accurate the rest of their information
was
oh pumpkin head jinx finisher for the
good side
they're in the beings category that's
right yeah i knew they appeared in the
uh
[Music]
and then it's interesting the centaurs
were like
no we don't
because i think the wizards were going
to consider them as beings as well but
they're like we don't want to be
included
[Music]
yo high iq warrior what's up dude
didn't get notified of the stream no
i don't know what all you have to have
checked to get notified of the stream
honestly make sure you have the uh
so there's a little bell icon
or actually when i post this during the
day
there should be a little button on there
where you can say um
notify me
i usually do that i did that just the
other day for james uh expect a go but
then it also might have something to do
with the bell icon too
let me go to uh
let me see i'm trying to find a channel
that i'm not
subscribed to so like apple here
so if i subscribe where is the yeah make
sure you after you subscribe make sure
you hit the bell icon
and make sure you set it to all
i don't know if that has anything to do
with the live streams but that will
i mean i think so right that would make
sure that you get
and then you can also do it on uh
i i did i was a little bit later in
posting this one though i didn't get it
posted until this afternoon so my
apologies high q warrior but good to see
you dylan when's the next let's play um
let's play
do you mean the oh you you're probably
talking about the prisoner of azkaban
[Music]
i thought for at first i thought you
meant the um
miles morales slash god of war live
stream whatever we end up doing there
um if you're talking about the prisoner
of azkaban let's play it is done
but
i'm trying to think of how much i can
say on this um that video is probably
gonna have a sponsor
a sponsor that you guys will recognize
i'll just leave it at that so whenever
you have a video that's sponsored there
are a couple more
steps that it has to go through people
that have to approve it so it is it is
done
it is just waiting to be approved
by the all the needed parties
so i'm excited for you guys to see it
though it is
i i have beaten the game and the next
one will be me beating the game
and then i'm thinking i might actually
do another one after that that will be
me kind of going around and getting all
the collectibles
but i have like
i have so much to do i want to i want to
also start a chamber of secrets pc let's
play i also want to do the let's play of
um
goblet of fire even though that game's
pretty rough
i have so many things i want to do man
like i don't even i'm talking about god
of war i'm talking about persona all
these like really long games i don't i
don't have enough time for all of it i
don't
but we'll see we'll see
oh wait what did travis travis got 50
point wait somebody lost points what did
travis do here
high wing is poppy and animagus form
are getting captured
censored down a dark path to take over
the wizarding world with the magical
beast fireside oh my gosh
oh man you had the belt and then
even then had didn't get notifications
oh
that's so weird yeah if you thought i
don't know if you have twitter or not
but i also i try to post it on twitter
whenever i'm going live
and then
where else do i post it
in the discord which i
i don't post in the discord as much as i
should but
as you guys can see from everything i'm
listing off here so many things that
need to be done really
uh no kevin you do not need to create
multiple accounts they confirm that yeah
so you'll you will get so if you play
through again a second time on a
different house
you will uh you'll be wearing the house
robes for that house so it's kind of
cool how they're implementing it you
don't have to worry about switching
anything over
or the item or anything like that
that's right feathers yeah that's what i
was trying to say so if i had had it
scheduled earlier in the day and you
happen to be on youtube and see it
there's a little button that you it'll
pop up a thumbnail just like it's a new
video from me
um and it could say like add reminder
and then you'll get i think that that'll
actually send you an email when you do
that
but that was kind of my bad because i
didn't get it posted until like i don't
know two or three o'clock
this afternoon something like that
yeah we've seen nifflers yeah
yeah that's right demonic
i'm wondering if they're gonna try and
explain that at all
the chocolate frog thing
yeah dude right sponsor
yep sponsor video like i've i've
hesitated to say too much because this
is
it's been in the works for a little bit
but
um it's like i've had a couple of like
i'm trying to think
i've done like some like i do the amazon
affiliate thing but that's not really
like a sponsor per se
so this is like like it's like really
our first big
big sponsorship going but um
all i will say is that you guys will
definitely recognize the sponsor
i was uh
i was very careful in deciding you know
whenever we take that step
you know you could do the nord vpns and
the uh
the the squarespace and you know those
those are great sponsorships but
i think i think you guys will be pumped
about this one i do i do this one's uh
right up our alley for an audience for
sure
but yeah as soon as it gets as soon as
they have approved the video it'll be up
it's already it's already done ready to
go oh is my dog moving around back there
yeah she loves hanging out in here with
me whenever i do uh
the live streams
there is a discord
let me see if i still have it i used to
have like a link um
append comment but i don't think i have
it anymore
yeah i used to have a pen comment up
here
[Music]
where you could get to the discord
let me think what's the quickest way
[Music]
probably to do this right here
i always have to make sure when i'm like
typing in passwords that i have the
right screen showing
even though it's hidden anyway but
oh
two-factor authentication
you know you gotta have it
all right so
i'll post i'll post a link here in the
chat
yeah i'd love to have you guys in the
discord honestly the discord is
something that i
i really need to put some work into um
you know what if you guys are in the
discord
shoot me a message in there
if you have any thoughts or suggestions
on like how we can make it a uh
more interactive more engaging for
people
because um i do post in there
again not nearly as much as i should i
just like discord is a thing now like
it's a big it's a big deal now and
really important to have
but i just like it's never been one of
those things that i use frequently i
mean other people use it all the time
they use it all the time and it's just
not something that's like in my daily
sort of
it's not something i check daily whereas
i feel like a lot of people like live on
they live on discord all right invite
people see i'm having to look up like
how i even or send a server uh okay i'm
gonna edit the link invite and i'm gonna
say
expire i'm gonna say this one expires
never
generate a new link
copy
all right i'll p i'll paste it here in
the chat
all right so there's the discord if
anybody wants to
hop in the discord so yeah let me know
like suggestions for
i kind of have it real simple right now
in terms of the different categories we
have
so i'm i'm all leaders like
if any of you want to be like moderator
or stuff like that
somebody to start discussions let me
know let me know
yeah no problem kevin legend of dragoon
i played that when it came out
i've never played that one
yeah a phoenix or a thunderbird in there
would be amazing a wizard harry
would be amazing
[Music]
hey have a good night djing thank you
for stopping by and hanging out
appreciate it
[Music]
hogwarts legacy discord is quite active
has a dozen permanent residents yeah i
see how uh like chandler posts updates
in there every now and then
change your name to something more harry
potter for youtube
it is kind of cool though i like i do
like your like the name you have
yeah i want to see the full uh character
creation
i do
jp do i have it in the description
good to know see that was like my past
self long ago i thought ahead and
thought oh it'd probably be good to
include that
so i'm glad i'm glad i thought about
that
oh but um looks like
zee air zaire said the link isn't
working hopefully that other one works
[Music]
on the discord nice welcome welcome
welcome
i probably should uh let me look at that
let me go to
so if i have it in a video description
okay well this is gonna be weird oh no i
thought i was going to be seeing myself
or okay
that's not going to work for me though
right i probably have to
what if i do an incognito window will it
work then
so i won't be logged in
and then if i scroll down here
hit more
let's see discord
[Music]
yeah okay i think it looks like it's
still working
hopefully you can get one of them to
work though either the one i posted in
the chat or that one right there
[Music]
i never did play cyberpunk no
i never did
nico put my store out there more people
need those shirts
oh man yeah i need to wear it more too
so
now that one there's a real easy way
because i was struggling with this last
time nico people were like what's the
store link and i was like oh i don't
know i gotta go to teespring
so i have set up retrorecontour.com
and it's basically just linking people
out to where all the places i met so
links you to the youtube links you to
the twitch and then i also set up the
merch page here
so what nico's talking about here is we
released some new merch a couple weeks
ago these order of merlin shirts i know
dylan got one dylan sent me a
picture of his over on twitter
i've seen a few others getting them as
well so you can get these through the uh
through the shop here
now if you want a discount code
if you go to my
i also have a newsletter
so on my twitter the newsletter is
through the twitter here so if you hit
like if you just go to my profile on
twitter start reading i think i included
a
15
off
or it might have been 10 so there's a
discount code
if you are a member of the channel so
for any of you who got gifted
memberships tonight
i don't want to pull it up on screen
because it will pull up the code so then
everybody would have it
um
but if you check the community page i
think it's on the community page
there is a section james thanks so much
for the super chat james
there is a section where
um it's like member only so you'll see
things that i've posted just for members
so we all these emoji that we're using
right now
um the members were able to get feedback
on those before we finalized so little
things like that so there's also a
discount in there for um
i think it's 15 off so if you're
interested in the merch and you got
gifted a membership
you can get a discount code from that
that you can use
so we got you know the retro hat i'm
wearing here a couple retro shirts order
of merlin posters different sizes mug
the stickers here
the stickers man i wish i could make the
stickers cheaper like you're a wizard
it's kind of crazy how much this like
i'm
the you can like set your prices on
teespring is the way it works but only
over a certain amount
so the stickers like cost a lot more
than you would think so i was like man
i'm basically just gonna
make nothing on the stickers but i still
want if people want the stickers to be
able to get them but 5.99 i'm like
but they are they are much larger i gave
both of mine to james expect that expect
a go i sent them to him but they were
like they're almost as tall as this like
soda can right here so they're they're
actually pretty big for the stickers got
phone cases in there for all different
kinds of phones and then the shirts as
well
so if you're not a member though and you
would also like a discount code
actually the one for the uh
this one might have expired for the um
i also do a weekly newsletter but so it
was in last week's issue i think
[Music]
yeah you can try code legacy in the shop
for 10 off okay so that's if you're
subscribed to the newsletter or if you
happen to be watching this right now and
see me pulling it up you can try that
one but if you remember you get a better
discount through the uh the youtube
membership but they're uh and as far as
the um
merch goes there's more on the way
so when i hired the artist for those
shirts
they also did a couple more designs so
they're the artists who did the little
emotes that you guys see right now for
the uh
the lion the badger the snake
and the eagle they did those and then
they also did two more shirt designs for
me as well
so there's one that's i'm gonna release
it around halloween
because it is uh it's very appropriate
for that time period
very very appropriate
[Music]
yo marvin dude you still got some of
those stickers oh that is awesome
i still i i have a whole bunch of those
stickers i still have some in my in my
drawer here
as well
jason heading out hey have a good night
jason thanks for stopping by
in game get the invisibility cloak ooh
that'd be pretty cool oh and james dude
james i'm so sorry james supporting this
the channel with that that super chat
james i hope you're still here dude uh
thoughts on a triwizard tournament so
if we go by the dates that we know of
the triwizard tournament it will not
happen in the game because it would
already have been
ended at that point
now
we do know from canon that they have
said
there were several attempts to bring
back the tournament
so here we go in 1792
this is from the harry potter lexicon
akaka trice the champ
a cocker trace the champions were
supposed to be catching went on the
rampage all three school heads were
injured
uh as the death toll mounted the
tournament was discontinued so this is
in goblet of fire
that we learned this so it was
discontinued in 1792
no one expected it to ever return so
then we don't have anything between then
and 1994 which is when the triwizard
tournament we read about in gobot of
fires when that one happens
but we do know that they made several
attempts to bring it back
i i don't expect it to be in the game
um
everybody asking that question though i
think there's they're spot on because it
would be like it would be great for a
game right having something like a
series of challenges that you go through
a series of trials makes perfect sense
for a video game
but i i don't think so no
be weird if there isn't a rival yeah you
do kind of need a
like an in-school rival you're right
hey thanks timothy yeah i'm pretty
pumped about the shirts too i think uh
i was pretty pleased with the way they
turned out
what if hogwarts legacy loves the merlin
design ask if they could use it for a
new rope in the game yo tom that'd be
amazing
[Music]
that'd be awesome
special edition uh merlin robe
[Music]
super carlin brothers theorized there
might have been a tribute tournament in
1894 oh dude i haven't seen that video
from them that's super interesting
though
so hogwarts legacy 1890 so we would just
miss that one too
[Music]
halloween we get a new trailer
i don't know i'm kind of thinking they
might slow down a bit
with
the marketing now
just a bit
because if you notice they had been
doing a those regular thursday updates
of new new things
this is what they posted today and for
those of us who have been following the
game super super closely like most of us
here this is not new you know we already
knew this at the back to hogwarts but to
their credit they revealed a lot at the
back to hogwarts like that was like
five thursdays worth of reveals there in
that one
back to hogwarts event
so
and then they like they did this on the
seventh so that was yesterday but these
are just like they're just kind of
re-sharing some of the things they've
already done so i'm i'm really curious
to see i think the next big thing they
show
will be at whenever playstation has
their event
playstation will have some sort of event
this year we don't know when yet
they will do something
um and when they do i think that is
where we'll get because chandler said
that we'll we'll learn more about the
playstation exclusives at a later date
so either it's going to be a playstation
blog post or it's going to be a
playstation event probably both is my
guess is when we get more of that
[Music]
that's what i think
[Music]
jenny weasley oh my goodness ginny
weasley with the five dollar super chat
jenny thank you so much for the super
chat show and support on the channel
and when we getting a hufflepuff
commenter breakdown my target is this
saturday for the hufflepuff video
if not saturday sunday
but yeah it is it is next on the list
for sure
dylan thank you for stopping by man have
a good night always good to see you and
chat with you dylan
where does it say it was trying to come
back they don't say it on this page
[Music]
but there is a
let me look on the hp wiki
which i always like to go to the hp
lexicon first because they deal strictly
with
they're a little bit more strict in uh
they kind of only look at things that
come from jk rowling whether through
interviews that she's done
whereas
the hp wiki is good it looks at a more
all-encompassing view
but it includes some things that
you know
let me uh search attempts
because i remember the wording okay here
we go multiple attempts had been made to
revive the tournament but none succeeded
okay so this let's see their source on
this
okay so this must be somewhere in goblet
of fire
that's what they're citing as the source
for this right here this whole little
section
so i don't have the exact passage of
goblet of fire but it seems like that's
where they're getting that
[Music]
a secret ravenclaw companion
uh what do you mean by secret like that
they're gonna keep it just because we
don't know yet i mean i definitely think
there will be a ravenclaw companion yeah
i definitely think there will be
oh templar i do agree with you on that i
think they i think they absolutely need
to show some gameplay
yeah
all of this stuff we've seen is great
and it's definitely pleasing the
hardcore
fans of harry potter but
for those of us who've played a lot of
video games we know that it's
you can make look something look really
nice in a trailer
but until we see the moment even even
what they the gameplay
revealed the state of play like that was
technically gameplay
but that wasn't someone
physically showing us what a mo like
moment-to-moment
character out in the gameplay
surrounding hogwarts what does it look
like to actually run around in casting
spells
what does it feel like to cast these
spells you know how does all that work i
think that i 100 agree with you there
story-wise i don't i don't really need
to see much else with the story i need
to see a little bit of the gameplay
i'd say like 10 minutes or so maybe i
think if they just showed off a little a
little side mission
not even the whole thing just show us a
little play through of a side mission
gathering some collectibles casting some
spells
starting the mission that sort of thing
i think that would be that would be
enough for me
uh chris found your channel recently
thanks for such an awesome awesome
hogwarts legacy coverage hey chris thank
you so much dude glad you found the
channel uh we do these live streams
every week normally we do them on
tuesday and it's really kind of just a
hangout where we
talk hogwarts legacy for a couple of
hours tonight we've been uh we just hit
we just crossed the three hour marks
we've been going for three hours tonight
um and really it's it's a very
conversational laid back
atmosphere i've been thinking about
putting these up as podcasts maybe as
well
as my dog has just like jumped up on the
couch over here now
but yeah so we uh normally we do it on
tuesdays but um any schedule changes
like that
um i always post over on twitter at
retrorecontour and i try to remember i
don't post on it as much as i should the
youtube community page because there's
also a little community page because i
know not everybody likes twitter because
i mean let's be honest twitter is a
well you know
you know there's a lot of negativity
there too um but it's it's real good to
get news out quickly like to communicate
with you guys so that's where i post a
lot of things and then um
and then yeah i need to make more of an
effort on the youtube community page
though
tom heading out hey tom thanks so much
for hanging out
hope you have a good night tom
yeah exactly jp yeah there's there's a
lot of negativity on there
a lot of negativity
only a savior with a two dollar super
chat sorry i'm late want to say hi yo
oni good to see you
you're never late dude
don't you remember gandalf's quote come
on now
come on now a wizard is never late nor
is he early
he arrives precisely when he means to
so you're here right on time oni right
on time
thank you so much for the support for
the super chat
before discord to twitter because it can
be moderated
you know haikyuu i never
i've never looked at discord that way
but that's a good point
that's a really good point
atomic dud don't worry i won't leave you
be cool if we get skins for the main
character's wands yeah people have been
loving uh
are begging rather for some sort of wand
customization so
i think they'll have to have some
element of that but also like make it
work so it'll be interesting to see
10 out of 10 get i don't know about that
feathers i don't know about 10 out of 10
but
time starts when gandolf arrives
yeah oni i'm really pumped with how they
turned out
i'm pretty happy with them i need to see
like when we unlock more
because i couldn't believe we had that
many slots open
the fact that we were even getting open
world rpg makes me so happy need the
gameplay to be playable right right
like
if everything we've seen
was just a walking simulator
and nothing more it would be it would at
least be cool you know
it'd be cool
but
if they have actually built a truly fun
game on top of all this
oh man it's gonna be so epic
it's gonna be so epic
scene bots uh catch swearing and
needless aggression in chat so it has
support for all sorts of user plug-ins
oh yeah yeah on a discord
yeah man like for any of you like i i
seriously mean this if any of you are
really versed on discord
and you're like passionate about our
community here and you'd like to help
the discord grow
shoot me a comment a private message
over on discord and just let me know if
you have some ideas because like i i'm
i admit guys like i am ignorant when it
comes to discord
and i know like people have such strong
community like james talks all the time
about uh you guys helping him out in
discord and uh
you guys talking theories and that sort
of thing and i've just like i admit like
i have not put the time into it that i
need to to
to fully understand it so
i really do mean if you have ideas if
you want to be like a moderator or
something i don't know do they have i
guess you can set moderators is that how
it works on there
oh yeah we posted uh i posted the
discord link earlier in
chat i can post it again here if anybody
missed it
uh let's see
[Music]
retros discord
[Music]
there you go for anybody who is
interested in that
[Music]
oh dude yeah i forgot about the poll let
me check on the poll
[Music]
oh dude i think ghost of tsushima oh
good sushima by two percent guys if you
haven't voted in the poll yet vote i'm
gonna close it in about one minute
which of these games would you be most
interested in watching me live stream
either on twitch or on here on youtube
god of war the 2018 one ghost of
tsushima pokemon legends of rc at
xenoblade xander blade's not gonna win
but you can vote for it if you want
keep it up for a couple more minutes
here
and then we'll go ahead and close it
down i also have a poll over on my
youtube community page
you can vote there too i actually have
an additional option there because
you can include more so if you are
oh dude now god of war it goes to
sashimar tide
yo i mean honestly i'd love to do all of
them eventually i really would i'd love
to do both of them
i'll be honest like i'm kind of leaning
god of war just because
i think it'd be fun to replay it before
ragnarok
and then then live stream ragnarok as
well but i don't even like if i only
stream one night a week i don't know if
i'd have enough time to even beat it
before
ragnarok comes out we'd have to have
like a day of just like
i don't know a day where like my wife
and the kids are
going to visit somebody or something and
i just
hang out and stream for a day
all right we'll give it 30 more seconds
on the uh the in chat poll here if you
haven't voted yet
uh if you if you want god of war you
could sway the vote if you want ghost of
sashimi you could sway the vote right
now ghost of tsushima still ahead by 3
3 of the vote right now for ghost
and if you're wondering i have played
all the way through god of war i have
played through roughly half of ghost of
tsushima love both the games but i
really
i really want to replay god of war and i
also really want to beat
um
ghost of tsushima
all right i'm gonna go ahead and in the
poll and it looks like
go sushima won that one among our uh
chat here
it one among the chat here
yeah i was thinking that too high iq i
was thinking that too
oh i can't
see nico i told you dude i'm so
i'm ignorant on everything there can't
receive private messages because of my
settings need to be friends for the ah
okay
that may be that may be why people send
me friend i get friends requests from
people sometimes i'm like
i don't know who you are maybe they're
trying to send me a private message
your vote didn't work no
wolf you could you could uh go on the
community page here and vote for sure
that one should go through
what difficulty that's a good question
templar i want to see how many
difficulties they have
because i may
i can see normal being
no offense to anybody i could see no i
could see normal being
more on the easy side
i could see nor their their normal diff
because i mean they gotta cater to a
mass audience for this game
a mass audience that they know
a lot of people are saying i mean maybe
some of you even hear it's like you
don't play a lot of games like you you
grew up a fan of harry potter and you're
loving the way this looks and you want
to play it for that reason
so most games i start off and play
normal the first time and then kind of
for my like platinum trophy second
playthrough run
i'll play on the harder difficulties
but hogwarts legacy depending on how
many they have i might bump it up
because i do i definitely want a little
challenge oh i just got a dis let's see
[Music]
hold on i do get messages from people on
discord but i guess maybe i've
maybe i've accepted them okay someone
named earth agent on discord just sent
me a message so i got that one i don't
think i'm friends with earth agent
oh there you go that's jake all right
nice yeah i don't think uh my settings
should be where you could still send me
a message because jake and i are not
friends
but um it let me
i got his message came through there
special ending on hard mode oh that'd be
nice
yeah jenny yeah and that's me not a big
gamer can't wait to play probably try
regular yeah
exactly and i i mean that's what i start
on most games is the just the the basic
difficulty
i mean because i i always see that as
like this is how the developers want the
game to be
played like this is the basic
play it on this
probably easy normal hard then new game
plus which is like hardcore yeah that's
a good idea too
melissa definitely definitely go with
the easy mode hard mode oh yeah i read
that one yeah hard mode could be a
really cool special ending
yeah i think eldon ring and some of the
souls games have done where
well they don't have hard modes and
things like that but where you get
different
endings actually based on what you
some of the some of the like most
elusive endings you have to do like all
these crazy little
especially bloodborne bloodborne had
like
to get actually to get the final true
boss of bloodborne there was some crazy
stuff you had to go and collect to find
in that one
yeah spartan difficulty modes yeah for
hogwarts legacy what they may be
i colonel yeah that's that's kind of the
reason i want to see gameplay too
because for those trailers
they're absolutely going to turn it down
to the easiest difficulty
because a lot of people pointed that out
it's like you know you've got a horde of
bad of enemies you know that you're
fighting but they were kind of just like
stepping up one at a time and casting
their spells
so i would i would think it'll be
cranked up for sure for the real game
[Music]
all right man it is getting late for me
it is after 11 30 so guys i think
i think that's going to be it for
tonight man yeah we'll be back on a pr i
think we should get back to a normal
schedule next week
and do a tuesday night stream
um but yeah man thank you guys so much
for being here
as always the the support has been
incredible tonight the super chats the
new members
the new subs
um
just awesome man and this this is just
the beginning i want to do even more of
these i want to do
like i mean i'm doing these polls i want
to get back to streaming games again too
because i think that would be an a
really fun
interacting with you guys in that way
like we're playing a game but we're
still kind of having the chat going as
well
how could you leave me atomic dudman
uh if you guys missed it you can always
go back and watch the vod
and for those of you watching uh this
later on the replay appreciate you all
as well this is these stay live up on
the youtube channel so
oh my goodness you guys hold on hold on
hold on
i gotta show you all this
look right here
i'm partial but like
is she not so adorable
is she not adorable
she's just like totally chilling there
she stays in here with me all day man
like i worked from home today
and she stayed in here the whole day
she's she really is like my shadow i
think it's because like my boys they're
you know they're wild and rough
and she's getting older now she's like
12 so
she likes to
you know keep it more low-key stay out
of their way
uh westy named luna
west highland terrier
you guys already know the name you guys
already know the inspiration for the
name
all right guys i'm gonna hop off here
check in on some youtube comments and
then probably uh try to get in bed get
some sleep maybe read a little bit
before bed but um thank you all so much
for the support man very much appreciate
it hope everybody has a great rest your
week uh and yeah man i'll talk to you
again soon look for the hufflepuff video
very very soon if you haven't seen the
others we got full breakdowns of
gryffindor ravenclaw slytherin common
rooms
plenty more on the way so everybody have
a fantastic night thank you all so much
for being here and i will talk to you
again soon we'll let the uh
let the outro play here for a bit play
the little music
but um
have a good one guys thank you so much
[Music]
you